okay good morning everyone welcome to
the meeting of development control
committee a um i just need to run
through some of the domestic
arrangements can i please make sure that
you do social distancing from other
people please when you're in the chamber
and in the uh in the outdoor communal
areas
can you please ensure that you do wear a
face covering at all times unless you're
sitting down or of course if you're
exempt from doing so
um please do use the hand sanitizers and
wipes that have been provided
can i ask you to ensure that your
microphones are turned off when not in
use and please do not interrupt other
speakers or hold separate conversations
while others are speaking
if you are attending this meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you will be asked to leave
can i ask you please just to double
check your mobile phones are at least on
silent or switched off and can you also
do the same with your laptops turn the
volume right down so we don't have a
chime of pings when our emails come in
please
we will be using e-voting for those that
are able to i know one member's
laptop is not working today but we will
be using e-voting for this meeting on
the modern.gov.app
so if members can just make sure you're
logged on those that are able today
i'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting has been broadcast live on the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewing the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being recorded and
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also conte consenting to being
recorded by the council into the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded if
we do hear the fire alarm today there
are no tests planned can you leave the
building go via the fire exits and make
our way to the ipswich town football
club assembly point
uh please follow the signs directing you
to the fire exits at the end of each
floor and do not enter the atrium on the
ground floor or the walkways
if you're in the atrium at the sign of
the alarm please follow the signs the
nearest fire exit signs and do not use
the lifts and do not re-enter the
building until we're told it is safe to
do so
good so that's the um basic uh health
and safety all dealt with so we'll just
run through some introductions so those
that may not have been to the planning
meeting before
my name is councillor matthew hicks
myself and my fellow colleagues here on
my immediate left
will be making the decisions on the
applications before us today
in mid-south district council a ward
member
may speak on an application
within their award but may not
vote on it so if that's the case they'll
be asked to sit where councillor heading
in the sitting
who has an opportunity to speak on the
application in her
award but not vote on it
just running around the room we have
philip isabel the chief planning officer
and john paytman g the area planning
managers down the end and we have the
case officers we have vincent here today
and others will join us as we progress
we have ian de prez our legal advisor
on
right and left of me we have the people
that make this whole meeting tick and
without them we wouldn't operate so
we're always very grateful thank you
okay so i think we'll move on straight
on to the agenda
uh do we have any apologies for absence
please
no receive chair okay do we need to
receive any pecuniary or non-pecuniary
interest by members
council field
[Music]
thank you i just feel i should let the
meeting know that i i am i'm not the
ward member for item f uh the
circular road in balan but i do live in
that village
and i am in the row of houses
which
there is only one row of houses along
main street so i'm certainly in that
i'm at least 360 meters from the
application
so i was advised that i can take part in
the meeting and i will
stick with that view at least until late
this afternoon so it's a non-pecuniary
interest
i can confirm councillor field took my
advice and i'm happy with what he said
okay i also want to declare a
non-community interest on item agenda 7d
that the architect for that application
has done some work for us in the past
okay
anyone else
nope thank you
uh declarations of lobbying
there'd be multiple um so
several yeah so if can someone just uh
for the
sake of everyone just go through the
numbers so we've all been lobbied on 7a
7b
and f
i have been to paris council meetings uh
as a county councillor for stonymaster
so those have come up in the past
okay i think that covers that off thank
you
um
[Music]
right so we now need to confirm the
minutes uh sorry any declarations of
personal site visits
yeah that's what i just said just said
it i've got it in personal site visits
yeah council mansell yeah
obviously we've all been to wakeling's
farm
as a committee or most of us anyway
but i was on the
committee some years ago that paid a uh
site visit to the uh points meadow
at rear of sight also
yeah we don't none of us need to declare
uh the wakelands visit because we did a
site visit as a
group there so that's fine yes
councilman uh thank you i i i was i
can't remember if it was i certainly did
a personal site visit to quotes meadow
when it was um here for the outline
planning permission um because i i
didn't realize there was a
an official one but i wasn't on an
official one i did my own
so that was a personal site visit thank
you yeah
that's really better um
i've
gone and had a look at the backton one
7b thank you thanks very much
well i have okay
but that was a must have been the other
committee
we haven't here in this country i have
okay thank you
okay i think we'll move on now to the
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 13th of october are
there any points regarding the accuracy
of the minutes that anyone wishes to
bring up yep councillor
matheson yeah
77.2 um the
it's evident that the
the application number
is is the wrong one
uh at the end of that it's not three
three one five it's it's whatever the
other whatever the next one was
um it's something else anyway
thank you for that we'll pick that up
apart from that item uh are we happy
that they're a true record if so can i
have a proposer and second councillor e
burning council password thank you
so on that basis we'll need to go to an
electronic vote
thank you chair members if you go to
your mod gov app
select plus sign on the top right hand
corner
this vote should now show in progress
plus humphreys thank you
councilman mansell your vote hasn't come
up have you
you have
um
thank you thank you chair that's eight
votes for that's unanimous okay great
thank you very much i'll sign those uh
at the end of the meeting
okay do agenda item six is to receive
notifications of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme have
any been received let me see
good okay thank you so we'll move
straight on to the schedule of planning
applications first one before us is 7a
which is uh dc
2101 735 wakelings farm in thressing
field and i handed the case officer
vincent pierce to introduce the
application to the committee
thank you chair good morning members
ladies and gentlemen
first item wakelands midfield lane
thressing field you will recall that on
the 18th of august this came before
that committee and members determined
that the application should be deferred
to allow an organized site visit
that site visit took place
on the 25th of august
so the presentation i'm giving this
morning
is an update on what has happened since
then
and
a few more descriptions to help clarify
points in the report but my presentation
should be considered
in relation and with the report as well
so
important um
layout amendments
let's go
forward
so that's the scheme that you saw before
you in august that's the red line around
wakelings
and blue land is other land in the
ownership of the applicant and as you
can see quite extensive blue land to the
west and a large site drawn around
wakelands the listed building
previously the
vertical
striped area was the area that was going
to be used for mobile homes
and the cross-hatched green area was the
area
where it was intended to have 12
pods
for guests staying at the
premises
i've turned that round so it now aligns
with how you would see that on a map so
that's august
in september
we received amended plans
and i would say they are significant in
so far as
you can see that the area for the
pods has been pulled away from the
listed building itself
you will notice now that there is a 25
meter buffer area on the east side of
the
site where in places the hedgerow the
established hedged row has a few little
gaps that you can see through so in
order to combat any fear of
seeing through from the public footpath
a buffer
is to be created
and also the
area where the blue arrows are has been
deleted from the application so that
means there will not be a mobile home or
mobile homes in that bottom section of
that
that field and again
you may have noticed as you walk around
the footpath to the south and the east
of the site occasionally you catch
glimpses through to that field
so
the applicant has deleted that from the
proposal
if we just superimpose that over the
aerial photograph you will see how that
fits into the landscape and you will
have noted from your site visit the very
characteristic strips of
cultivated land between which are long
rows of of trees the site is very well
screened around the edges by existing
trees and hedgerow
the whole of that area is some 3.6
hectares so the area for the
glamping pods is large
nearly nine acres
within which would be placed 12 pods
just to help you picture
size a a
normal adult sized football pitch is two
acres
so you can see there that you've got
more than
four football pitches within which there
would be 12 small pods
the area for mobile homes 1.36 hairs set
hectares or 3.36 acres
again that would only have six mobile
homes on that site
it is worth pointing out that the
application site straddles two parishes
thressing field and matfield
and that is significant because we have
a divergence of view locally between the
two parishes which i will go into some
detail in a little later
so on the books we have freshing field
parish council who recommend approval to
you
metfield parish council strongly objects
and mendem parish council objects so
this site sits
at the cusp of three different parishes
technically menden parish is outside of
the application
area but it is immediately adjoining one
corner
i won't go into the extensive objections
from
metfield they're all in the report
but i myself have summarized them
for the purpose of this meeting as
traffic parking and other hazards
disturbance and harm to residential and
visual amenity
appearance
site management how the police will be
operated the level of use and the
activity
and potential enforcement matters
well i have to say this morning that any
enforcement matter that may
wish to come forward from objectives is
not a matter for this committee that is
a metaphor outside of
this committee
but as i go through the presentation i
hope to address
all of the objections from
metfield and then you will have to
decide whether or not the changes have
adequately dealt with
those concerns and again men
less objections but the the gist
is the same in terms of traffic
incompatible with the ecological
stability and sustainability of the area
and the
pods whilst innovative are intrusive
and as i say fretting field supports the
application
the boundary runs thus
so the majority of the site
for the pods will sit in metfield
and potentially the site for the mobile
homes sits almost equally between the
two parishes depending on where the
units are cited
freshing field does have a neighborhood
plan the other two parishes do not so
you can see the site there in red right
at the edge of the thressing field
neighborhood plan
area the report provides a lot of detail
as to
relevance of
neighbourhood plan policies
i particularly draw your attention to
fresh 13
which says new small-scale business is
appropriate to rural areas particularly
those that result in reuse of redundant
and unused historical farm buildings and
new buildings to accommodate new
business or agricultural uses will be
positively encouraged
provided they do not have significant
adverse impact on the character of the
area amenity of residents or
unacceptable increasing traffic
generation
the neighborhood plan also supports the
promotion of tourism
it also requires that new developments
should take the opportunity to provide
safe and attractive pedestrian and cycle
links and you'll notice that suffolk
county councils the relevant highway
authority have no objection
but they have stipulated they would like
to see a condition requiring the
provision of passing spaces
on metfield lane and i can
go into a little bit more detail in that
a little later
the site sits at the hub of an extensive
network of public footpaths
and fresh six in the neighborhood plan
requires
landscape to be protected
within the neighborhood plan
a series of views important views are
identified in thressing field none of
those views include this part of the
neighborhood plan area so the site
isn't within one of those areas defined
as as being particularly sensitive in
terms of views
as you all know fretting field sits at
the north
east corner of the
district nudging south norfolk
and close to east suffolk
there you can see the red square is the
site sitting between fretting field and
matfield connections to it are by
country lane
the two largest roads the b116 and the
b1123
run diagonally but do not connect to the
site
so once again here we have the site
and the dashed line is the parish
boundary
the site
is ringed by a series of footpaths and i
imagine that when members went out on
site they walked some all or part of
that that network
so the site is visible in terms of it is
wrapped around two corners two sides by
that footpath network so it's important
that we have a
take account of how much of this
development might the public see when
they're traversing footpath 20 2039
there's a shot awakens in the
snow we have wakelings itself is listed
and we have two listed buildings to the
west metford lane farm
and metfield lane
farmhouse a short section of video so
here i'm standing
behind the barn i'm looking at the
implement store you probably saw that
on your visit this is an area that would
be used for parking
for
events
this is within the heart of the site
end of the barn in that
cart lodge area is where the woodland
haberdasher
has a workshop
this is the bakery on the other side of
that barn and if we swing round to the
left members will recall that there is
a toilet block and those toilets have
showers
here we have the site in the north east
corner metfield lane
and you get to that it's effectively a
dead end you get to that on
the road that's between thressingfield
and metfield daisy hill which becomes
freshing field road
members will have done though i don't
know whether every member here was on
the site visit or not but i took the
advantage of popping out and taking a
little short section of video just so
that we can see
the how you would get to the site
assuming that works there we go
because obviously there has been
many expressions of concerns about the
suitability of this approach to get to
the site so it is a single lane track
verges on either side in the ditch
on the left
we're just passing the um
land quip site who
involved in
sprayers
and you'll notice as we go around the
bend that's a sharp right hand bend
commercial use to the left
on the right is a
is the lanquip site we have a
number of residential properties coming
up on the right
so we are getting out into the
countryside
or more countryside at this point
the road swings around if you can recall
that trip that you made two and a two
and a half months ago
open fields on the right
the land on the left is largely in the
ownership of the applicant
and this is where if members were minded
grant planning permission a series of
parking not parking passing spaces could
be
provided
by members to accept the recommendation
of the ohio authority so you can see
that two vehicles
cannot pass so the issue is how do
visitors to the site and existing
residents some of which live down this
lane how to ensure that traffic moves
freely and safely you can see that
people put their wheelie bins out
so i assume that a dust cart a refuse
freighter can go down there and it goes
right down to the end to
wakelings
again this is area where passing places
could be provided
we're coming to the end of that section
of metfield lane and soon we'll just
swing around to the private drive to
wakelands
and i think it is fair to say that we've
put a lot of thought into
whether or not this is appropriate for
the sorts of activity that are being
proposed
but i think we also have to bear in mind
that the site enjoys the benefit of
permitted development rights for
temporary uses
so
the site could be used at the moment
during the kovic crisis for fit 56 days
of the year
for
events
normally it's
28 days of the year that can happen
without any control
by the planning service or this council
so that track can be used for those
activities with impunity
if we
move on from
that is the um formal correspondence
from
suffolk saying they have no objections
subject to provision of parking by
passing bays
in terms of those passing bays you can
see here
on the video all this area on the left
is within the control of the applicant
and so
any number of
passing bays could be provided
what happens on the site where you've
seen that for yourselves there's
an organic veg
business
we have
the wakelands bakery that uses products
from the farm
we also have the
woodland haberdasher and we can see a
series of
events that are being
promoted
so you can see that there are things
like hand spinning
making twine
also just an example you will have seen
that there's dying of wool so that you
can do your own
craft knitting so here we have an
example of
wool that's been dipped in wood that is
grown on the
the site
i would suggest that all these are
country crafts
you will have seen the
the pods on the site you will also know
the characteristic rows of trees and
these are an intrinsic part of the
particular
style of agriculture that is being
undertaken on this site sustainable
agriculture each of those strips is
capable of being cultivated
i think you would have to accept that
those pods are completely
well screened from outside the site in
those locations between the
rows of trees a close-up of the pods
they might look a bit funky they're sort
of primary colors
but because you can't see them is that
really
a worry in terms of impact on the the
countryside or the listed building
so here's a plan of one of those pods
so an entrance
double bunks on the left
toilet home basin
and
again that's also the red one is the
shower the green one is the hand basin
the suggestion is to have mobile homes
you will have noticed on site well you
won't have noticed because they're not
there this style of mobile home is
currently not in place but the idea
would be to
swap the units that are there
the smaller
mobile almost caravan style and replace
them with
this style of
unit
each of those units would itself be
further concealed behind either hazel
hurdles or willow
hurdles
and again that's just simply to help
disguise their presence should there be
any break within the trees
from the outside but also remember we've
now secured that 25 meter setback
again there's every opportunity to do
traditional
hedge layering to reinforce the planting
and the applicant has agreed to
reinforce planting where there's any
gaps
parking i do want to spend a little bit
of time on this because when you went
out on site you'll have noticed some
parking spaces we show those on the left
hand side
the main area of parking as shown on
this drawing is that sort of
area where there's a hodgepodge of
bits and pieces of
typical farm
paraphernalia
and it strikes me that if we are to be
certain that adequate parking is
provided i think we need a better plan
than that
and i think also when we come under the
section 106 agreement that we are
suggesting you'll notice that
parking provision becomes an important
part of that section 106. we do need
more detail about how events will be
managed in terms of parking so whilst
the parking shown on this drawing i
would suggest is adequate for anyone
turning up to buy a loaf
i want to have a quick look around the
site but for events we need something
far more comprehensive and we have
secured that through the 106
if members are minded to go down that
route
so there are the parking spaces that you
will have seen
you will have seen the bakery
this proposal is retrospective those
works have been undertaken simply to
effectively re-roof it
new cladding
and some additional
windows but the
the important thing is when you saw that
piece of video that i played at the
start in your site visit it matches
perfectly the existing barn i think you
would have to accept that it is
perfectly
fine in terms of its appearance
and its traditional rural character
the good thing is that there's the
original building if we move that over
it wasn't increased
in size during that network it was
simply
refurbished inside
i imagine you looked inside
you have a
high quality high standard
bakery
here's a little area around the back
where staff can sit at a rest break
there has been quite a lot of discussion
about
locally about these fire i was going to
call it a fire pit but fireballs and the
extent to which that represents
a fire hazard
that is also a matter that we can
control through the section 106 and i'll
explain that a little bit more but i was
thinking
during the summer
at home
on a balmy summer's night there were any
number of
barbecues on the go gymnast people
sitting out around a fire pit and i
didn't notice anyone being particularly
concerned about
the fire risk so
i might come back to that a little later
in terms of the ditches
that's the ditch network around the
the site each of the
glamping pods will have a
an orthodox cassette system for feral
water like any other
caravan on any other type of caravan
site
the content of those will be put into a
large cloud gesture where it will be
broken down
organically and in an environmentally
friendly way as you suppose you might
expect on a site
that is proposing proposing a
a sustainable alternative way of life
here you can see some of the
organic vegetables growing in those
strips between the
trees
that is all available for local people
through a veg box
service
here we have the an aerial view again
those strips of trees
you can see some glamping pods there at
the moment when that photograph was
taken they were right at the heart of
the
site and i think there's been some
concern expressed in the representations
that we've received that
the sighting of those glamping pods will
limit
prohibit or even constrain the amount of
agriculture that can be undertaken on
the
site and i want to explain to you why
that would not be the case shortly so
there's a
there's a strip of the vegetables
growing between the trees
that's the bakery
some more strips
one of the existing caravans on the on
the site
there's a strip that is ready to be
planted
now
what is operated on the site is a four
year crop rotation system they don't use
fertilizers
so each of those strips isn't heavily
fertilized three of the strips in any
one year are left what i would have said
fallow
but they described as lay so on the
three brown strips
they would be planted with
either peas or buckwheat or clover and
that is ploughed back into that to fix
nitrogen
in the soil in order to keep the
fertility up but it's only the green
strip where
crops are being produced in that year
the following year
that moves to the next strip the
following year the next strip
and so on
which
was the great innovation from the
mid-17th century the agrarian
revolution
so in a sense they are going back to
that style of organic
farming they don't use manure
so the idea of ploughing back in things
like buckwheat and peas
provides
fully organic status for those
strips and the products that are grown
in them
also i think it's important you will
have noticed a lot of hazel plantation
and those hazels are planted in twin
strips
and that's important because what
happens is
one year one row of
hazels are coppiced cut to the ground
the straightest and strongest
staves are used in
traditional rural hedgelang but the rest
are used for biomass
for heating the house and other parts of
the site so all of those
tree products are reused on the site to
generate
heat
seven years later the other row gets
coppiced so what's happening is all the
time
there is a mature section of hazel
hedgerow and that provides
constant
screening for anything that's happening
behind those those hedgerows
here you can see one of the crops that
would be plowed back into the field to
fix nitrogen in the soil
again we've got the footpath system you
will have walked around that section
which is established dense hedgerow
this section in green is the area that
now will be set aside where members to
grant permission
again you can walk through here and that
is
established hedgerow and then in here we
have
woodland going to the north
quick turnaround just to reinforce the
fact that it is mature
hedgerow each of those
points that was yesterday so it is
up to date and can you see the twinned
groups of
hazel plantation there
site is highly sustainable in terms of
there is a large bank of pv panels
that's an electric vehicle i've already
explained the the biomass
element
this is the site just throughout down
the road land quip
sprayers
that makes quite a presence on the um
frontage to metfield lane but it is
something you would expect to find in
the countryside that's there to service
farms
where are the neighbours i've done a
short analysis
so here's
weight cleanse
each triangle is what i
have
estimated to be a single dwelling based
on the ear or photograph and the dots
are a cluster
so the nearest
property
metfield lane farm
as the crow flies is a quarter of a mile
away
from the nearest part of wakefield
sorry wakelands farm
i would be hard-pressed to imagine that
somebody having a fire outside of the
glamping pod
or enjoying a laughing a conversation
would be readily noticeable from the
nearest neighbor
i've explained
that the site already has the benefit of
temporary use right permission as anyone
in the countryside
would have
and that at the moment can include 56
days of activities they are completely
uncontrolled and what i'm going to
suggest to you
is that if you were minded to grant this
planning permission it would allow the
council to bring all of those activities
under control
through the management plan both within
the red line and the blue line
so i'm going to throw the challenge to
members when you're discussing this
what might be the better
better alternative
i do want to run through the 106 because
i think it's important
we have ensured that the glamping pods
mobile homes all fall within the statute
definition of of caravan
now this is important because it means
nobody can
establish
youth rights for a dwelling house nobody
can secure residential use rights to
expand
it also means that we know how big these
units are they're not going to be
two-story they can't be stacked on each
other they can't loom over the hedgerow
that gives us a lot of control that you
don't have at the moment
the
glamping pods
and home mobile homes will only be
allowed on the site if they're connected
with an operation at
wakelands this can't be a general
campsite it can't be a
people can't come here for a holiday
they have to come here if they're
attending one of the events or special
days special weekends at the
at the site
the mobile homes can only be occupied by
those actively working on the
on the site
so i think what we're trying to
establish through the 106 agreement
having listened to the concerns of the
committee and of the parish councils
last last time
is something that prevents this activity
and this site growing like topsy
we want to
restrict it to the absolute minimum
necessary to continue the
sustainable agricultural activity that
that happens
again we've secured that buffer strip on
the eastern side
this is important because within the 106
there is reference to any event
where more than 20 people are likely
will have to be a ticket bought in
advance
only arrangement so in the marketing
people just couldn't turn up on the day
and i'll go into a little bit more
detail of how the management plan would
work
but i can understand that for people who
might be living on metfield lane the
prospect of having an event where any
number of people could randomly turn up
is actually quite daunting in terms of
the impact on their amenity and perhaps
their even their ability to get in and
out of their own property and pop down
to freshen field or wherever they want
to go
on the
network of country lanes so here we
would have an opportunity to have proper
stewarding
and i can think of examples from a
previous life in a previous authority
where just this sort of mechanism worked
very successfully
you could have a steward at one end and
skewered at the other end with
some sort of walkie-talkie and if a
resident wanted to get out you could
stop the traffic and then let that
person in or out but it relies on a
degree of cooperation between all the
parties
so the management plan i've said
events of more than 20 people must all
be pre-booked
the 106 will require the applicant to
enter into regular dialogue with the
parish councils the local parish
councils with a view to
explaining what's happening sort of
forthcoming events
and to explain what
protocols
will be in place to protect amenity
again
parking will have to be the subject of
separate consideration
also within the management plan we might
want to consider phasing entry
so that not everyone turns up at once
rooting will be pre-agreed
as i say hedging reinforced
drinking water is supplied or will be
supplied to each of those units
fell water will be dealt with
environmentally friendly ways
other waste will be recycled electricity
will be supplied to all the pods and
mobile homes and as you know
pv
and other sustainable ways will be used
to provide that electricity
fireballs and and nighttime noise will
be subject to the management plan and
there will be a 24 7 duty phone for
anyone to contact should there be any
hint of a disturbance or nuisance
only 12 pods and six mobile homes ever
that's how we stop it growing like topsy
all of those units must be kept in a
well-maintained condition so through the
106 if we would turn up and they started
looking a bit ramshackle
they would either have to be immediately
improved or removed
the positioning of the clamping pods
will be restricted to areas where they
won't be visible from the outside
but i think there may be as i said there
may be some confusion as to where these
pods will go the pods will only be
allowed to go on the fields where there
is no crop so
as that crop rotation
moves around so will the
pods
the planning balance in the officer
report goes through all of those in a
great deal of
of detail so what we've tried to do is
tackle all of the issues raised by all
the representatives to come to our
conclusion
and our conclusion is that
with the benefit of the section 106
agreement as i've described we are
satisfied that the use
is acceptable um we are suggesting some
additional conditions as well
rather than the parking condition that
appears in your
agenda that says parking provision to be
created as shown on the plan
i think we're going to suggest further
detailed parking plans to be submitted
and that will be required through the
section 106
we will also have a condition
suggesting that the landscape
reinforcement happens sooner rather than
later where appropriate
and we're also suggesting the removal of
all temporary use
permitted development on the
site by
condition
as a backstop so i think what we're
saying is since august we have secured
amendments and assurances through the
working of a 106 that would actually
deliver
a better situation than we had in august
and i'd like to suggest that we have
dealt with the issues adequately thank
you chair thank you just before we go to
questions phillip do you want to come in
at this point
uh thank you yes if i may um
just to pick up on a couple points
you'll see uh the highway authority
recommended an additional condition uh i
think that should be in your
table papers regarding um potential
passing paces by way of condition that's
one element uh as regards the question
of uh managing temporary uses uh as uh
vincent has suggested uh we'd expect
that to be within the section 106 rather
than by condition because clearly this
is a planning application which is not
for those temporary uses so the section
106 is the proper place to put that
and and lastly
members will have seen quite a lot of
paperwork uh lobbying around the
development
i'd remind members that clearly
there may be issues there that are
planning issues that weren't
uh examination but it's important to
remember that the identity of an
applicant is not relevant to planning
the nature of the use of the land and
the extent of
the application before you
is relevant and this is not an
application for a change of use
for those other uses and events this is
an application
for glamping pods for mobile homes and
for a bakery element so
it's important to bear those
distinctions in mind um i'm conscious
that there are a lot of strong opinions
in all sorts of directions around the
application and it's important that
members direct themselves appropriately
and have got any questions around that
and how they should treat matters please
do ask myself or mr deprayne i don't
know if mr duprey has anything to add on
the lobbying question whilst we're
talking about well yes um chairman i
don't
i'm aware i've been made aware because
my advice has been taken and the
monetary officer's advice and the
monetary officer and i agree on this
that
i don't want to take up the committee's
time but if if necessary i'll just say
something briefly about the law on
lobbying so it's well again
as as members know lobbying happens a
lot
uh as in contact either people are the
applicant or objectors or whoever
contacting directly
counselors who are going to be on the
committee and it is perfectly lawful
i mean a couple of years ago there was a
case in the high court involving hackney
council because hackney had with the
very best of good intentions banned
lobbying for a while but the high court
said no you can't
it raises human rights issues and our
freedom of expression it's
part of the process and if you if
you had a case in the crown court across
the road you get into very serious
trouble if you try to lobby a judge or a
jury member but this a planning
committee is not a court of law and
although there's a habit as a risen
local government of saying these are
quasi-judicial proceedings actually in
hackney the high court said no that's
not quite right
um it's a more in a more informal and
essentially administrative process
and it it can't be stopped now having
said all of that there's another
principle that's extremely important
which is
transparency and fairness and
the consequence of that is sometimes if
lobbying takes the form of an extensive
or significant document piece of writing
sent to you
it
well we all know that i think
experienced members of the committee
know some developers make a habit of
sending you brochures and all sorts of
things last minute and not
including the case officer or anyone
else in and but when they come to the
attention of the officers and members
are very conscientious in passing them
on to us
we will put them on the website but that
that has to be we have to treat everyone
equally so
in this case there has been some
extensive uh written material that has
gone on the website so everyone can see
it and no one is disadvantaged whether
they are an applicant or an objector or
whoever so i don't think i need to say
any more than that but i'll answer any
more any questions if members are
concerned thank you okay so questions
i'm sure we've yeah we've obviously got
a lot so we'll just start at the front
row and work along and work bachelors
start with you council password yeah
thank you very much uh matthew good
morning everybody a couple of questions
we talked about the passing place
uh i think we'd be interested in a
little bit more detail and i would
question is one enough
because there's quite a long and those
of us we i think we all went on the site
visit it's quite a long route up once
you get beyond the um spray sprayer
machine
depot and i do think there was a letter
in the papers from one of the people who
lives further up the lane and where her
driveway or his driveway has been used
as a passing place
now and you can see if it happens to be
wet we know what happens to verges and
so on it gets all chewed up and does
look a bit of a mess so i'm questioning
whether one passing place is enough if
permission were to be given and i think
we ought to have a little more detail on
that if possible please
um
you mentioned the colors of the uh
um of the pods and so on
to me they are rather garish and i just
want sorry we're not at this point
allowed to express any views at all
sorry can i just ask this question
yeah all right i've got all that thank
you yeah so
[Music]
how are you sure you are confident that
will not make any material difference if
things changed or something in 10 15
years time
i do have a concern on that
regarding what we do and the other issue
there is when it comes to if it won't be
given permission you mentioned that
enforcement isn't really for this
committee
how would that work though because if
permission was given clearly
we would have to make sure enforcement
does take place and a lot of it's done
on trust so how how can that be done
thank you three questions
thank you councillor passport i
am perfectly happy to accept that more
than one passing space place will be
required
uh apologies if i gave the impression it
was is singular
the county council have said passing
places
we as no it might have been how i
described it so as part of the
management plan
we would ensure with our county
colleagues that
passing places were properly formed so
they would have a hard surface they
would be free draining and stable we
wouldn't just be saying it's it's a bit
of earth
sort of
dug out so in that sense we would be
we would be sure that they would be
usable and that they wouldn't create
mess and mud and everything else
in terms of the colors of the pods
technically the management plan could
pick up
long-term maintenance of those pods if
members were so minded
i think it would be harsh to say that
the
the blue and the red and the yellow have
to be repainted because i truly believe
that they will not be visible from a
public vantage point in amongst those
trees that far from the boundary
i think it would be
unreasonable in the planning sense
um in terms of enforcement i think there
is a real advantage to the council in
having a robust section 106 compared to
conditions because the answer was simply
would be to take out an injunction
so if there was a serious breach of that
106 you go straight to court and seek an
injunction
now the question is
would the council be brave enough to do
that i see no that's a question for phil
but i can think of many occasions where
authorities have done just that
so that would be my my triple response
to your questions thank you so can i
just remind members
can we just have very short questions at
this point just just to um
speed up the morning
uh councillor matheson you're next we're
working along the line if you're happy
to go otherwise councillor field
i think that the the questions that i'd
be wanting to ask would be to to the
applicant agent actually thank you thank
you council field
thank you i i just uh
to the extent i'm overlapping with
councillor passport but
i i wanted to be sure on the issue of
passing places the officer
put that in the plural extended plural
throughout his presentation and the list
at the end of the presentation said
passing place
singular so i would want to be really
clear on that bearing in mind we all sat
to a presentation by a eminent barrister
yesterday where he said one of the most
vital things is we're absolutely clear
about what we're agreeing
and i don't want to see us agreeing to
passing places undefined number in
undefined places
and have a condition that says passing
place singular so perhaps you could
reassure me on that
my second question really was the one on
we've been asked to swap 56 days where
there is a right to um
hold any event on wishes that's uh
half the weekends in a year two days
each will be a way of thinking about
that for the possibility of 365 days a
year and the basis of the swap is that
we
will be able to enforce a number of
standards
is this the enforcement service i know
so well
or is it an improved one and the issue
of taking on an injunction i think in my
20 years as a counselor i've known us do
that once so perhaps people could just
expand on that before we get to
debate i'm sure that the chief playing
officer will want us to address the
second half of your question but the
first half i
readily accept my typing
error and i will absolutely confirm
on public record that we are talking
about
places
many plural not singular places
chairman if
if i pick up on that
um
so so the advice in your table papers um
from ben chester letter 5th of november
describes condition described passing
places
it will be usual to provide a passing
place uh relative to
uh
what they expect as standards for
distance and and traffic volumes so i
don't know that at the moment the advice
we have is plural places and that's
written in the letter the draft
condition
that mr chester has suggested
uh is on the second page of that letter
and it talks about new passing places
along uh metfield lane generally in
accordance with the drawing dm06
which i suspect is a standard drawing
that the county provide about the design
of a passing place doesn't tell you how
many
how many you provide
but this will be a technical matter from
which the county will have experience
and we would take their advice and
clearly it is a long single track route
so that we'll need
uh thought
and design but the condition will allow
flexibility to manage all of that that's
perhaps that's the start of the passing
places point mr pearce can correct me if
i've got anything wrong there
um
the second point
about
use is i'm not aware that this planning
application gives any right for events
this is a planning application for a
change of use for mobile homes or
glamping pods
and for the retention of some work
system buildings it is not an
event-based planning application what
the application
what the applicant and
officers have
resolved upon is a way of managing the
28-day rule uses that we know and love
56 days this year as presently stands
but effectively managing those
activities and that's what's described
in section 106 so it isn't
letting the floodgates of that as i read
these papers uh chairman it is allowing
for management of uh the rights that the
government allows every every landowner
to have
um relatively free and unencumbered to
do things for a period in any one year
and anyone can do you
so it creates that
opportunity to
manage something and manage it with
consultation with the community in a way
that doesn't presently exist and we have
seen i think in the correspondence
the
differences of opinion about how that is
which hopefully this might bring to
uh some measure of dialogue
the question of an injunction
from our point of view as officers
we are perfectly content to see
conjunctions where that's reasonable
we've always had a period of
uh kovid which has precluded us from
seeking those things but uh i see no
reason why he wouldn't enforce in that
way and use that right
um
if we were required to if we needed to
if it was expedient
thank you councillor manson
uh no i i don't have any questions at
this point thank you for i just like i
think it was a very thorough um
presentation so
all my queries weren't
vincent you just mentioned i just want
some clarity that
um obviously every two months these
clamping pods will move
where will they move too is it the same
area
it could move anywhere within
the area that is not being used for
cropping
within the defined
cross-hatched area so i imagine the tele
hoist will come in
and just move it and the reason for
keeping them moving
is so that the soil underneath
isn't
adversely impacted in order to maintain
that organic status
catheter no more questions yes council
having
thanks just a quick one um you mentioned
about touring caravans and campsites and
saying you know you can't come on
holiday here but what are the
restrictions can they not do it anywhere
under permitted development
they can and that's
that's what i think is the
at the heart of this what i think is a
mechanism for delivering the control
that
chief planning officer just described at
the moment that could happen
but on the back of the proposal to
have the pods the mobile home and the
bakery
we've agreed a position where all of
that comes under control of the 106.
so at the moment that could happen
now if you were minded to grant this
this would come under control
and that's that's the
interesting part about where we've moved
since the last meeting
thank you can i just ask so under the
section 106 is there any capacity is
does it reach a capacity number what so
you said the minimum if it goes over 20
it has to be ticketed
is there a maximum number at which you
would say that's too many
there isn't as it stands
obviously
each event would have to be pre-agreed
that would give us the chance of saying
well that's likely to attract more than
competition when you say pre-agreed
pre-agreed with us
but i mean because it's never we're
create if we're not careful we're
creating a huge amount of work for the
mid-south district council that every
weekend we're going to have to be
looking at numbers which isn't we don't
have that capacity the management plan
is pre-agreed and if we do it
as i imagine we're going to do it as
i've done it elsewhere
different types of event you'll almost
agree by different capacities
so you will have pre-agreed what happens
if it's between 100 and 200 up to 500.
so therefore if there's no actual
capacity how do you know the car park's
big enough
because
you would only allow
as many
people to come as you have pre-agreed
if you think there might be a ceiling
figure of the number that
would be
harmful
there is no
nothing
to stop us actually agreeing
a ceiling limit
based on how much we think the site
could accommodate
okay
yeah
mr chairman sorry just for clarity
because as soon as you're getting
wrapped around the events wheel on this
one this isn't a plain application for
events so i don't know where this this
actually comes in
why are we debating it
that
that is because i haven't introduced the
idea that
were you minded to allow the 12
glamping pods the six mobile homes and
the bakery uh building changes we could
secure a mechanism
that would bring all those other uses
under control so you're right it isn't
formally part of this application
but we have taken this opportunity to
bring something under control that is
normally uncontrolled
move on
so for
speakers now so we first of all go to
metfield parish council uh who've come
today peter mortimer you have three
minutes uh and the time is here and we
do ask you to keep the three minutes
please over to you when you're ready
right thank you very much mr chairman i
appreciate we wrote this the last editor
and there's things come to light this
morning that we didn't know about but i
will read
i would like to state that metfield
parish council is not against the
diversification of redundant
agricultural buildings but i was
constrainedly concerned about the impact
of the local infrastructure and
environment in the long term
potentially presidents set within this
application having completed the site
visit you will be aware that the farmers
situated in an isolated position that
means activities are not always visible
although the pods and caravans can be
seen from the local roads and the noise
heard
this should not mean the planning law
does not need to be adhered to because
things can't be seen but it does make it
difficult to police as the playing
officer noted at the site visit there is
another two buildings that were in
construction that are not part of this
application that might need to be
included
enforcement may be upon the upwards
important to regulate this site
by their own admission wakelands has
already held up to 240 visitors in the
two bay events which was equivalent to a
half the population of the villages of
metfield currently 2 and 409 without any
control in the additions of more
enterprises and increased campaigning
etc it may not be long before daily
visitor numbers increased dramatically
the development of the site seems likely
to incorporate a set of unconnected
enterprises with no overall management
the applicant has no intention of living
on the site the farm house is no longer
available as a permanent residence
permission is currently being sought for
the sighting of caravans on the site to
provide alternative accommodation
we assume the authorities not limited to
planning environmental health
enforcement will be looking into the
long-term implications of leasing the
land to individuals with respect of
access and long-term occupancy
scientists are visiting the site to
study the current biodiversity but this
akane is a separate to the running of
weightlifting itself
is there a qualified scientific lead
management to assess
to ensure this long activity with the
addition of large number of independent
enterprises pods caravans and campaigns
surely diversification
will suffer in one sentence the
applicant claims awakens as a heritage
ashes this must be protected yet in
another he is happy to have cars parked
across the land and to access routes
across the headlands and we hope that if
the passing places are put in which
you've been talking about this morning
they were built by suffolk highways and
paid for by the applicant
there's not much made about the need for
accommodation of the agricultural
workers there is a lack of clarity in
this application for those running the
individual enterprises are actually
contractually employed by weightlings
all types of farming not limited
agriculture arbiculture and horticulture
need to make money to survive and as
such it seems odd that weightless should
be allowing the use of its assets
without recompense if the individual
enterprises cannot afford to pay current
market rates for the use of facilities
are they viable we ask the question
objectives have asked to see the
business plan which the applicant has
said is not relevant to this application
but with its current ad hoc nature
multiple positions and changes already
how can the local community be confident
about the development when it is
constantly evolving without any regard
to the local area residence and planning
legislation and i thank you very much mr
chairman for allowing you to
put this presentation together on behalf
of
metfor parish council thank you very
much okay uh questions for the parish
council yeah councilor madison
yeah i think this is probably going to
be a question for the officers actually
but
as we've
started to to explore through questions
to to mr pierce
the um
the concept of events and so on um
there's
some point at which
an event that's been planned
um
is
is brought to the attention of our
environmental health
department
and i just wondered
where that where that threshold comes as
to what sort of an event i mean right if
it's got alcohol we know that it's got
to get an alcohol license but
just in terms of numbers of people as as
as the the representative from the is
raised um you know at what point would
we consider an event as something that
that should be
subject to some controls in general
terms not just this
specific
place that we're looking at at the
moment
i am probably getting rusty on licensing
but then i was never entirely
okay with it to start with as a as a
planner i know there are things such as
music licenses alcohol license dancing
licenses event licenses i don't know
whether my colleague mr dupray can help
based on his previous
licensing law requires that if you
haven't got a premises license
you you must
have a temporary event no to give a
temporary event notice the council for
um this
supply of alcohol or regulated
entertainment or late night refreshment
which means
non-alcoholic hot drinks between 11. let
me get this right 11 p.m and 5 a.m so
and anything yeah as you say as you
suggested councillor matheson
through chairman the
alcohol or entertainment most i i could
talk all day about what's regulated
entertainment what isn't but i think it
everything you'd expect more or less um
would uh
yes
so i don't if i could help any further
than that
it only gets me a halfway i mean
it's perfectly reasonable to think that
that
would be we're talking here about an
event that would not involve alcohol and
would not invent
involve music actually um
or
and
regulated entertainment james um yeah
i'm not quite sure what it is but um
basically
music music and dancing showing films
more or less um
yes
outside this the scope that you're
describing i could look up the
definition online quickly if you if you
i think i think we need to consider the
every things outside of all of what mr
duprey is going to come up with when you
listen to if it helps i'd quite i'd just
like to have one quick point councillor
matheson
obviously as you say licensing dealt
with by a separate
yeah you know
people who might be listening set the
thing but what i would say is if your
concern was how
if noise was creating a nuisance then
obviously our colleagues in
environmental health have a whole
strand of law to themselves the
under the environment acts where they
can take action against
noise nuisance
so
as well as having planning conditions
they are perfectly at liberty to enforce
their own
legislation if that was where your
concern might have been coming from
okay well let's move on and maybe come
back to see if we you hear anything more
okay so we're going to move on uh no
other questions to the parish council at
this stage nope thank you very much for
joining us today um next we go to an
objector mr paul mccann and again at
three minutes please
yes good morning everybody um i wish to
reiterate and reinforce a number of
concerns expressed by many people
regarding this reapplication
contrary to comments made by
prestonfield paris council this has
never been a safe issue
i'm a member of state but only
individual people not serial complainers
with bona fide objections also it makes
it very difficult to respond to this
application when the applicant's
response to objections has been posted
11th hour thus denying people the right
of reply
notwithstanding this i shall continue
with my original presentation
the need to diversify and make the site
commercially viable can only be achieved
by significant development resulting in
increased traffic light pollution noise
and footfall none of which are conducive
to wildlife the proposed amendments the
original application relate exclusively
to the proposed siting of the pods and
static caravans
the visual impact of the glamping pods
was a major concern of objectives and
the heritage team
this will be impossible to monitor and
enforce as there is no on-site
management the planning authority is
unlikely to see these matters as a high
priority
for their enforcement team indeed in
preston field we've had ongoing problems
with the lack of monitoring and
enforcement of a build in the village
the quantum of accommodation remains as
before with the potential for having 96
people or more in permanent and
semi-permanent accommodation
the noise and light pollution from all
of this accommodate accommodation will
be significant a number of proposals are
put forward by way of conditions many
are straightforward management issues
but compliance cannot be guaranteed for
example rules are proposed for the use
of the fireballs there is no mechanism
for monitoring this in the absence of
on-site management
wakelings is presenting itself as a hub
of diversification within the rural
economy with the emphasis being on
sustainability and the supporting of
flora and fauna awakens farm the fear is
that it will become an unsupervised
holiday campsite on a site of this size
this is hardly conducive to protecting
the environment
wakelands is located at the end of a
single track lane there's only one way
in and out suffolk county council have
been required to use specific small
refuge vehicles
the passing place recently created by
the applicant is not large enough for
anything more than the car
to be of benefit to a rural community
and its nature a development must be
sustainable and this is not instead it
would be forcing a host of problems onto
the land and neighborhood
setting a president for so much
invasiveness of inhabitants inhabitants
and
habitat sorry an amenity in deeply rural
countryside would be harmful
quoted recently in the media wakelings
really does stand out like an emerald
isle you can see such a contrast with
this very open farmland all this
greenery the trees and hedges that's
removing carbon from the atmosphere
that's the main aim when it comes to
tackling climate change this application
seeks a change of use to develop the
site way beyond its potential i would
urge the committee to reject this
application on the grounds of
non-sustainability thank you very much
chair thank you very much um questions
yes council humphreys mr thank you uh
just a
point really um you said 96 extra people
how did you get those figures please
you said 96 people would be on site how
did you get those figures i'll work it
out to be 48.
basically it was down to the number of
people in the farmhouse
the glamping pods the static caravans
uh which came to 96. okay so i've seen
the plans sorry about it i've seen the
plans of the caravans four people in
each caravan and the pods two bunks in
each uh i equate that to 48 people not
96. it's definitely below 96. thank you
we'll ask the case officer to calculate
the number that that could be just get
clarity on that i saw another hand go up
yes council mansell uh thank you chair
uh my my question is actually uh
probably of the officer but um uh the
speaker
talked about light pollution
and i don't seem to think there was any
we haven't heard anything about the
lighting um that was proposed so could
we just clarify uh what lighting is
proposed thank you
i concur with
councillor humphreys precision
four times six is twenty-four two times
twelve is twenty-four which is
forty-eight
in
if you added on four in the house
52.
in terms of the response to your
question councilman obviously we're not
looking at street lighting we're looking
at sustainable alternative ways of
of living i can't imagine there's going
to be any lighting perhaps a candle or a
some sort of lamp a torch but i can't
imagine it's going to be particularly
prominent
any other questions
no okay so we'll move on thank you mr
mccann um now we move on to we have two
supporters uh between you you have three
minutes and the
the clock starts so then it's between
you to delegate how much you want to
split between you but you have a total
of three minutes
hello and thank you for the chance to
speak last time you heard from henrietta
who runs the wakelands bakery and fey
the woodland haberdasher today you'll
hear from me maisie i work with
henrietta in the bakery and chloe from
real veg csa
and we are proud to say that wakeland's
bakery is the only
100 whole grain sourdough bakery in
suffolk
using organic ingredients
we have proactively sought small local
shops and markets because we see the
huge importance and value of interacting
with our local community
and lowering food miles
our baking days are 12 hours long and
the nearest place i could stay is over
an hour's drive away this would be
completely unsustainable
and i want to emphasize how henrietta
and i manage the entire fruit harvest at
weightlings as well as bake
this will be the first time in 25 years
that all of the lakeland's produce will
have been harvested and processed
and we also cater for and run courses
and events on the farm and a part of the
overall team which ensures wakelands
runs smoothly
including by providing 24 7 duty cover
and these activities require us to live
on site and be in the immediate vicinity
our business is viable but it's only six
months old and doesn't yet generate
enough income for us to privately rent
in the local area
without the pods the ability to live
cheaply on site and our integration with
the wakelands farming and other
operations our business would not be
viable i'll now pass over to chloe
hello uh we're currently producing
uh 25 organic bed shares every week from
veg solely grown at wakelands the
majority of our produce goes to our
members living within six miles
we are community supported agriculture
and therefore work closely with people
from the local community who come and
help us in our agroforestry alley
growing on less than an acre generates
enough income to provide a livelihood
but not enough to pay for the high cost
of renting a house in a nearby village
wakelands is giving us as new farmer
entrance an opportunity that would
otherwise be closed by providing land to
grow on and a place to live
crucial to our success is being part of
the overall awakens team and approach
as well as our own growing we are also
involved in harvesting the fruit and
part of the overall site management team
we help run and host events and courses
and provide veg shares to those course
attendees and to potential farmhouse
guests
and in order to run our activities we
need to have immediate and constant
access to our land
until we were able to stay awakens on an
interim basis in a caravan we had
regular operational
problems causing crop damage
on behalf of all of the enterprises at
wakelines we sincerely hope you see good
reason to grant planning permission so
that we can continue to build on our
early success at wakelands
please do not hesitate to ask myself or
maisie any further questions regarding
our enterprises thank you
thank you very much um
um guess i've got some questions but i
think i'll wait till i hear from the
applicant so then maybe come back to
either of you anyone else have a
question at this point
no okay thank you very much we move on
to david wolf the applicant
thank you very much uh thank you chair
committee um can i first of all thank
the committee for taking the time to
come and visit we really appreciated
that can i also thank um four senior
members of the council's planning team
for coming and visiting on several
occasions and the attention they have
given our application
and the highways department who again
have visited on two occasions including
on the second occasion a senior planner
um we welcome that scrutiny and that has
been a great help to us um that has
allowed us that has allowed us as you've
heard in discussion with those officers
to develop a series of
voluntary measures around section 106
agreement which go well beyond what is
in the planning application
which we welcome we had no intention we
have no intention of doing the things
that people fear
but this gives comfort and confidence to
everybody that those things will not
happen they will not be what people fear
and
one of our sadnesses is that some of the
objectors have not engaged with those
voluntary things um in what appears to
be a spirit of openness and
imagination and sometimes this has felt
like a personal campaign not just
against me and my family but against
maisie chloe rachel uh henrietta and all
the others and that's very sad and we
wish it was different
one of the problems of the process and
your lobbying process has been that a
whole load of things have been said
including in a letter which i've seen
which came to you from medford parish
council in the last couple of days
which are based upon simple
misunderstandings of what we're doing
and of what we're proposing um of what
is on our website um
what we can do with community
development rights and so on if you have
any concerns about those at all please
ask me please ask me if any of that is
playing on your mind please ask me
that said and my third point we are
proud of what we've achieved at
whitelands you've heard a bit about it
from maisie and chloe um you heard
previously from henrietta
we hope to be able to bring other people
in a similar fashion to weight lines to
do more of those things we think they
are a cause of celebration um whether
it's community apple days as we held a
couple of weeks ago a community
butterfly day we held in july
agroforestry open weekend earlier in the
year
or an organic farming event um for some
60 people who came from all over the
world and we are proud of those things
and that brings me to the final point if
i may
um
earlier this week um the oxford
university nature-based solutions
unit
launched a new website um and i'm just
going to read you from their website
this is a unit in oxford university
which specializes in tackling the
biodiversity
issues
and in tackling climate change and they
said this
today sees the release of our new
interactive global map of best practice
examples of nature-based solutions
across the world
funded by the british academy and
launched as part of the cop 26 climate
summit in glasgow the interactive map
links nature-based solutions to climate
change adaptation and it continues i'm
sorry the time is up can i take one
second you have no you have one sentence
one sentence
um there are ten sites in england on
their map two are farms we are one of
them a best practice example
okay any questions for the applicant
yeah counselor hattingham
i'm happy for the committee to start but
um
so i've got a question around is this is
a difficult one because obviously we're
getting this is around a planning
application but then this the section
106 is being added on top which we've
we've been talking about so can you just
talk us through
the control measures that you see being
in place to allay some of the
discussions that the residents have so
for example
um
we've all been sent photographs of last
weekend lots of vehicles going up on the
curb crossing into fields and getting
stuck in the mud and then having to be
pulled out
um so we've we've got that but you're
going to put in planning for a park so
you're going to put in parking places
and have a 24 7 contact number so do you
envisage that will stop you ever having
to do what happened last weekend which
obviously we've all been sent
photographs of how do you
you know is one going to help the other
um
so last weekend uh 10 days ago was a
great success 150 people on site doing
fantastic things um we we in response to
concerns about parking in different
areas we tried people parking in a yet
different area which meant that the
traffic and the people didn't drive past
our neighbor's house and we thought that
might um help her concerns
it meant that we parked we had parking
on area where um the grass wasn't as
mature as it would have been in other
areas so that was a an experiment if you
like
in terms of that being churned up and
muddy um
um
farmers plow fields feels becoming muddy
is not a concern
um in terms of cars getting stuck
actually only four cars got stuck and it
wasn't a problem it simply wasn't a
problem um we just easily move them with
a tractor or shove them out
is the new what you're offering going to
stop that happening so are you planning
that parking will just be in the new
area or are you still going to be using
what what we would do is we would um
because as you've heard from uh mr
pierce the the farming rotation means
that different areas are in a different
uh phase at any one time what we would
do is we would put parking in areas
where the grass has been growing for the
new car park will not be big enough to
carve out all the parking from the
events
so i'm not following the question the
new car park
that is being that we've seen a picture
of will not be big enough to carry all
the parking from all the events
so the parking in and around the
farmyard is more than adequate for
everything other than larger events
for larger events what would you do can
i just sort of explain everything you've
answered the question so the answer is
no you will not have enough capacity at
the car park for the events it's purely
for the farm activities
so i don't think that's what i said
sorry
for larger events which we can do anyway
as you've heard
we need to use areas of
grass around the farm the area we used
last week was not an optimal area
because it had only been dropped
but you've answered the question so the
new car park is not big enough to
cater for all the events
you'll still be using fields and parts
of the yes sorry exactly yeah thank you
cancer
a chair if i may i with all due respect
i think that's somewhat unreasonable
because lots of organizations have
one-off events in my patch lots of
farmers and landowners have one-off
events and they use a field and if it's
raining people get stuck i do think
my you know i'm i think they've answered
the questions about parking with the for
the bakery and time but i think it's
unreasonable to expect them to do a car
park what i'm just trying to clarify is
is the new car park
the final answer but it's it's not and
you can still hold 56 events there and
park anywhere yeah but we wouldn't
expect it to be
any other questions at all yep council
madison
yeah yeah i think i think two really
stemming from from what's just been um
talked about in terms of the parking and
so on did that was was there an a
different
entrance to to the whole site being
discussed or was experimented with there
or was that only in terms of of um
of the the parking place
and the second question really is i
think we that
based on what you've already heard from
various people uh to the officer and so
on um
if you could explain rather more how the
site management will work
um in terms of of
day to day
and and
then scaling up from that to
to larger events so how that would all
work when we we've we've heard from from
the supporters uh the businesses on
there what what they are
um
expected to to be able to do and then
we've also got the 106 which talks about
um a duty manager
phone number
but but clearly there's a point at which
on-site
management of what's going on
would become necessary from time to time
so if you could actually just explain
how that was
intended to work i think that might help
people
and so i think the first question was
about um uh access
um
no so well well um i made myself
see it on screen look at slide things
uh
you're putting a slide up sorry isn't it
slide six is quite good
[Applause]
that that isn't the whole side
that isn't the whole site
um
that's quite hard to work
in your pack you can look and look at
the one in the pack
slide six on page 92 of your pack might
be more helpful i don't know
yeah that's it that's the one
so so um
as you may recall if you look from the
bottom of the plan you drive up metford
lane you go past landquip the road then
bends to the right and then you go along
the bottom of our boundary the blue line
there um
that is completely open so you can
access our fields anywhere along there
there's no there's no ditch there's no
hedge there's no nothing it's just the
field goes onto the road so um you can
access the hole along there then as you
turn the corner and go north
uh up the side there's no there's no
access to our land there because there's
a ditch and a very mature hedge then
there's metfield lane farm just beyond
it there's a field entrance about there
where the pointer is so
we've used that as an entrance for
parking before and we've used the land
as sort of north and west of that as
parking for that work very effectively
for the open weekend in the uh spring
and you then go further north you carry
on up the road with the point out stop
there you can either go along our
concrete road which is what's marked
within the red line there thank you very
much or you can enter the
field blue area at that point and
there's a whole area there which again
depending on the rotation is available
for parking so there's effectively
several entrances to different areas of
the farm because of the way because the
road
comes along our boundary does that
answer your question
so there are options if you like
and then the second question was about
management so
um
we already have and have had for some
time a 24-hour duty phone and a number
um we've never yet had a complaint call
on it um we get calls from people making
inquiries about coming but we've never
had a complaint call on it yet it's 24
7. um that is always held by somebody
who was on site and that's one of the
advantages of the team of people there
there's always somebody in that position
um
when there are events and things the
events are normally being run by smaller
events like the classes that mr pearce
talked about are generally being run by
people the team who you've heard from
but if we have external people like
we've got a mead making course next
weekend um
there will always be other people there
because in fact henrietta and maisie
will be providing lunches for the people
who are involved in that course so we'd
never have a situation where one of the
weight claims one or more the wetlands
team wasn't there when we've had the
larger events like the open weekend in
the spring the butterfly day in the
summer and then the apple day last
weekend all of us were there and 150
people came but the
the greater as it were the wider
weightlings team of people who were
looking after that was about 25 people
that included three people who we
employed three young people who we
employed as parking marshals
so there was a parking marshal stationed
at the end of metfield lane there was
one directing people onto the field and
there was one immediately outside our
neighbor's house the medford lane house
to make sure she had no difficulties at
all and there were no difficulties at
all so
that's exactly the kind of thing we
could easily build into um the
management plan that mr pierce is
talking about and we would be happy to
do so so there would never be i mean we
don't want uncontrolled events don't get
us wrong this nothing of this is being
imposed upon us by the council these are
all things we would have done anyway and
so we're very happy to put them into an
agreement with the council
thank you yeah that is helpful thank you
any other questions uh cancer field and
councillor hattingham
just two i think
one of them you you rather dismiss the
issues of
muddy fields and needing to recover cars
i was just a question you surely that
creates compaction of the soil and
substantial drops in yield and you are
a farmer presumably that's important to
you you might want to comment but the
second one perhaps more significant
is that we've discussed the number of
passing places
and
i'm sure as councillors we all know that
county highways charge considerable sums
for
i was just wondering how many you're
anticipating on that road
we don't seem to have got a clear answer
otherwise
um can i deal with a second of those
first if i may um
it's only been in the last few days and
i didn't i didn't know until yesterday
that the county council had sent another
senior engineer out
and that they were suggesting multiple
passing places i don't have a problem
with that um indeed it's great um uh we
will have to pay whatever they charge um
i don't i don't know how many they have
in mind as mr israel said i suspect it's
a technical question rather than
something that we will have any input
into they will say
my hunch my guess is they will say one
north of medford lane farm and one south
of memphis lane farm but i have no idea
obviously we just have to suck that up
um
on the other aspect um uh
we we well in in last saturday we parked
in two alleys on the farm um
there were never more than twenty cars
at any one point in those alleys
we have 56 alleys across the farm so no
alley will ever suffer a great deal of
stress through parking
[Music]
as i say you've got photographs from our
neighbor who's made a concern about um
mud you know the field being made muddy
well it was made muddy but it's being
plowed up in a couple of weeks so i
don't want to make light of it too much
but um that is what we like what we do
um i don't believe there's an issue with
soil compaction we don't have a concern
about that indeed we may even in due
course go to a no-till um kind of
farming which is better for climate
change and so on um so we won't even
have the problems of softness that we do
at the moment through ploughing so i'm
you know we're
thank you i've just got um four but
they're quite short so don't panic um do
you still consider weaklings to be a
research center you said last time that
your parents received grants from both
the board and the uk you also said that
science experiments could no longer
carry on is that was that the right
understanding and have the grants been
withdrawn and if so why
uh let me try and make sure i understand
that so so um
uh my uh
so the research grants were um grants to
the organic research center principally
at a point where they had a team of
people based there so they had about
eight people based there in the office
building that you've seen doing
experiments there so they received grant
input and they paid a rent to my parents
as a literally a premises rent for using
facilities um the orc are no longer
there in that capacity and the grants
are no longer available because they
were eu grants um so and my father's
died so that's not part of it so that
doesn't mean there's no science going on
indeed um you may have seen so there
were some concerns from uh two
objectives metfor power council and
another about continuing science that
provoked um the orcs principal scientist
to write to the council a couple of
weeks ago to reassure the council that
the orc
is very much doing work at weight
cleanse
they are doing a project which is
involved it's across europe project um
it involves six
farms across europe okay so it's still a
research you're still doing research
thank you
okay um next question how many people
does weightlifting's actually employ are
they full time and what do they do and
is any of the accommodation for them
how many people do we actually employ
um well all of the people you've heard
from henrietta faye maisie have a number
um
uh they're all on a contract and they do
work for us yeah so they're available to
do the numbers and the numbers um well
if you count the other people uh 5
12 at the moment um but i would expect
more because everybody who's there as
one of the enterprises will also be on
our
contracted to us to deliver the kind of
management stuff that you've heard about
currently 12 and you think it will go to
20 plus thanks yeah okay yeah next
question who will actually own and
maintain the static care events who will
own and maintain caravans um probably
the occupants of them
and last one is um faye last time spoke
of the mobile homes being used just for
the first year of the start-up business
to get them on their feet because
they've heard that nowhere else it was
just faith is that right or um the the
uh well that may be her personal
aspiration i have no idea um
uh
the point about them is it's up to six
it's not a fixed number of six um and
the restrictions on them mean that they
have to be occupied by people in those
circumstances so it's entirely possible
that
they would be four for a while and it
would go to two and then it might go up
to five depending upon the the ebb and
flow of those people and if so if faye
if her business thrives and she's then
able to afford to live in thressing
field for 750 pounds a month which is
the minimum price um
then and she chooses to move out then
either somebody else will move in or
that unit will disappear for that period
so it's not a not like a fixed thing
it's as accurate yeah
any other questions
no okay
uh so council having them over to you
thank you very much
um so i should i suppose i should stop
the fact that local um opinion is indeed
split with three of the parishes um
involved i've heard fretting field then
support but mendel and most affected
metfor parish council do not
my own um you know i'm conflicted myself
to be fair but um but i would also point
out that i've heard from many more
residents that do objected this then
then than support it
but i do want to um thank the officers
involved and the applicants for the
amendments and assurances they've given
us and the work they've done since this
was last heard
[Music]
so i commend dave and amanda for
supporting young artisan artisans like
henrietta faye rachel and chloe but
they're very they're taking a very the
farm in a very new direction far from
its research roots in the name of
viability
those working within the enterprise
although i've just heard differently i
thought they were not contracted by
weightlings although they do benefit in
kind so there's no evidence to
suggest they require agricultural
accommodation as employees to the farm
i feel it's offering accommodation as an
option not as a necessity or part of an
employment um contract
it seems to me they're not agricultural
workers um like i say whether they're
employed by rakelands which is news to
me but the accommodation is being
offered as an incentive rather than a
necessity
the definition of a rural work is key
that is there a claimed need for
permanent workers on-site is there
proven an essential need there's no
instances here and this is a quote from
the mppf where farm animals or
agricultural processes require on-site
attention 24 hours a day and where
otherwise there'd be a risk to human or
animal health or from crime or to deal
quickly with emergencies that would
cause serious loss of crops or products
the only thing that would need attention
would be the occupation of the pods and
farmhouse and possibly a large number of
people camping in the in the pods and
yet um
you know it's this he's expecting the
occupants of the caravans you know who
might be employed by him or not to
facilitate this 24-hour
role on his behalf
the consideration on page 22 whether the
need could be met through improvements
to existing accommodation
of farmhouse which is now being used as
holiday accommodation was it once
thought that no one needed to live on
site can't this be used to house
visiting researchers and the like or
possibly workers with an essential need
to be on the site
does the veg box scheme really need
on-site occupancy to people live at
their allotments the baking days have
been quoted as three per week does that
require 24 7 presents
if an enterprise isn't able to sustain
sufficient income to provide a living
wage surely this suggests that the
enterprise isn't wholly viable
wakelands was never designed to be
profitable it's just too small at 56
acres this application is to take the
farm into completely new business which
should be judged by its own merits not
based on a legacy from previous
scientific research
my issue is that the proven essential
need for year-round occupation mr wolf
says that says for seasonal workers um
he if it wasn't
if it was for seasonal workers he
wouldn't be here that would be allowed
under permitted development i just can't
see the need for six static caravans for
up to six families to have to live on
this site thank you
thank you yeah questions for the world
member yeah
mr thank you um just a point really you
said agricultural workers and i've read
through the papers it quotes rural
workers i'd like a definition of which
is right please
the mppf now refers to rural workers
rather than agricultural workers
thank you mr chair
that's fine
okay any other questions yes council
madison yeah i was going to a very
similar place without i was um
perhaps keep keeping it back until we if
we got to a position where we were
discussing the conditions
and that is that the
um
on
sorry let's look at the page again yeah
i mean on page 19
right at the top um
officers are
are talking about
agricultural
working people working on site within
the agriculture and forestry operations
and i've i wondered whether
food processing for example
fell within that or not but then i
talked i turned to what the the
condition was
that was suggested and um that that
actually talks about it's mobile homes
essential workers
and dependent relatives and um
so i i just wondered
you know what exactly
we mean
there and and whether it
whether the condition actually covers
what what is proposed
that we've heard and what well what
might be proposed i suppose you would
say because we we're basically sort of
talking about three
three of the six mobile homes
effectively have got
um
i've got us a micro business attached to
them now um i just wonder if we you know
where
where the you know essential workers is
doing the job so you've lost what is the
specific question
is
the report at the top of page 19
um
agriculture and forestry operations um
and
and in in the recommended conditions
we're talking about essential workers
and and you know are we are we correctly
covering the ground that's intended
let's put it that way so it's okay
vincent can you just
can you answer that
i think we can make it clear that we are
talking about rural workers in that
condition we are in your hands committee
if you want it to say that that is what
it will well so you're right a lot of it
is agriculture but you may say that
spoon
making and basket making is not
agricultural but it's a rural craft and
we want to be sure that we've
embraced
the sorts of activity that you would
expect so we can adapt the condition as
you see feature
okay if there are no other questions oh
yeah councilman
yeah um
counselor having
freshman field parish council are in
favor of this development
um they have a fully formed and adopted
neighborhood plan
do you feel you've reflected their
opinions in your submission today um
before yesterday they'd only written two
lines in which are in the paper the
original papers how they felt about it i
felt they were not they were
ambivalent should i say that they
weren't um against it but they weren't
if they hadn't written reams of we think
this is marvellous they've written two
lines until we all received the letter
that um came from die yesterday that was
all i've you know heard about it
okay so i'm going to move us into debate
uh now we've heard from everyone it's up
to us to discuss debate obviously we've
done site visits we've
we've heard from the applicant we've
heard from objector supporter and and
some of the parish councils who came
today and we've had written
correspondence so over to us to discuss
debate cancer even
um thank you chair um i didn't ask um
questions normally i asked quite a few
during a planning
presentation of a planning application
but i felt that
it was covered in so much detail and
almost too much detail
within the presentations and the
speakers to the point i think we're in
danger of micromanaging somebody else's
business
and i think we need to be very very
careful about that now obviously i'm the
first person to speak in debate and i'm
not um and i will listen carefully to
what everyone else has to say but i
think
um
in essence i think it's a shame that
there seems to be an issue about what
used to be with this site and the people
that used to run it and and that's not
what we're about we're about what is in
front of us um who is currently running
this site what it will look like in the
future and that's what we should be
dealing with
um equally
you know we we all live in a rural area
and we need places like this to
diversify and not get lost
you know this is a fantastic to me
um
example of different rural businesses
there are people um you know there seem
to be questions about people's contracts
and so on so forth that's not for us to
consider you know people are trying to
set up rural businesses in a in a place
that's been much loved for years um and
i feel that we should be supporting that
um i understand people's concerns about
um
the access but i think that we can um i
hesitate to say put our faith in suffolk
highways but they have said that they
have no objection and will
and it's up to them to provide the
technical specification for whether it's
two passing spaces or
a hundred i'm sure it won't be a hundred
but you know
it's not for us to determine how many
should be it's for the technical experts
on that front
um
similarly there's been discussion about
what's what's happening on the site you
know and about holidays versus kind of
courses well frankly an awful lot of
people in this country go on holiday
because they are undertaking a course so
i think it's very difficult again for us
to say well if i'm doing a course of
basket weaving over a week that would be
you know that would be a holiday it's
not you know
it it's not
necessarily kind of
you know one thing or the other
and um i do think that
yes there's been a lot of local concern
but i think often in these cases you
don't hear from i've never heard a
parish council
in support of an application describe it
as marvelous
i think if they don't have any
objections they tend to kind of put one
one-off comments and um leave to that
it's when the objections that they want
to go in much more detail on something
and i think you obviously you hear from
people who are objecting and got
concerns um but we also don't hear from
those that have been to the site and
that have been
enjoying it um
and i think ultimately i think that
um i i would commend the offices for
their their work on on this application
but i'd also commend the applicant i
mean they have put forward a ream of um
of conditions that they are
voluntarily putting forward to ensure
that they um
any fears from from residents
and i feel as a committee we should be
supporting this and i appreciate chair
on the first to speak but i would be
very happy to support this and i'd be
happy to propose
that we um grant
um this um
planning application but i'm
conscious that i am the first person to
speak thank you very much that's right
i've i've had lots of hands we've got so
it was
next was councillor humphreys then
councillor mansell then councillor mayor
mr chairman thank you very much i can
care with much of what counselor e burns
just said um this site already has
diverse range of business and event
activities
that employ rural workers and it's
really important that we support that
and that we support
innovation and businesses in the
countryside really important it's also a
great place to go and the course is
extremely popular so it serves the wider
community
it's evident that at the moment local
residents are using that narrow road to
go past wakefield farm
so this would bring an enhancement for
everybody by bringing in passing places
so that surely is a good thing
although two parish councils object
again as we've heard pressing field
support it and i do get your point cause
had england but this is a normal
response from a council of supports and
it does support it and it states uh the
application as a benefit to the parish
would make a positive contribution to
the local economy the amendments would
mean accommodation screen from public
footpaths and manage traffic uh under
obviously the county council and
highways
and and again i'd like to commend the
applicant really for
basically your flexibility in changing
the plan to mitigate the adverse effects
that this could have caused so well done
you and and it's nice to see you being
proactive
um clamping pods clamping pods are
common throughout the uk they're widely
used on rural areas is diversification
of a business which people need to do
nowadays because the world's changed and
glamping pods are popular so why
shouldn't we support this application
and these are well screened the mobile
home application up to six and as we
said it can be reduced to zero depending
on the worker requirement and chloe and
um
maisie i'm glad you spoke because it's
nice to hear from somebody it's actually
going to benefit from this project
because it now allows you accommodation
in an area that you probably wouldn't be
able to afford to live in on the wages
or
activities you're conducting at the
moment i don't know what they are but it
makes it inhibitive this allows you to
continue business and to live where you
work and we all talk about people having
to travel for work this is an ideal
situation where they're on site why
wouldn't you support that
it's really good
so i believe it's reasonable i think the
accommodation is required i think the
diversification of the business is good
otherwise you wouldn't be doing it would
you and like say the changes layout are
fantastic so i would support this and
i'm happy to second the motion uh for
approval thank you very much uh cancer
mance who are you next uh thank you
chair uh i i too would like to concur
with uh almost everything that um
councillor ebern uh said in her you know
opening uh thing
uh and i i think this is quite a
complicated application and i think it's
a bit muddied
by all of these events which of course
if we decide today not to grant this
planning application those events on 56
days of the year will still go ahead and
i'm sure we've all been to countryside
events in the countryside where parking
is on a farmers field
and yeah it gets muddy and occasionally
tractors have to pull cars out of the
mud because
it's wet
um and that could still go on whether or
not we grant planning permission today
um
and yeah i too um completely agree with
uh with council humphreys about isn't it
wonderful that these um young
entrepreneurs will be able to live on
the on site where they work and not have
to drive up and down that field lane at
the beginning and end of their the days
when they're working that is actually
going to reduce the traffic along that
along that road on a day-to-day basis
okay so when they've got um all 48
people staying in the pods and
the and the vans and they've got an
event there will be more traffic um but
i and i and i think this is a
fascinating project i i was i i actually
thought it was quite honoured to be able
to go and have a look around so thank
you very much for arranging the site
visit
too was going to second councillory
burns proposal i i think we should go
along with this application and i too
think that the officers and the
applicant have done an awful lot of work
since uh this was first brought to us in
august so thank you very much for doing
that thank you cancer field
shook me um
yes perhaps to add a a view in the
opposite direction to an extent
um i i feel we're we're trying to
determine whether this application meets
the requirements of the local plan
we're not really here to be
saying it's something we
like and admire and we wish to wish it
to continue
the applicant is clearly trying to
support a historic and valued farming
experiment
that is not viable
with a range of businesses that are also
regressively not viable
but are giving rural
employment and certainly provide
courses etc that are good for mental
health etc of a wider population so
there certainly are some positives there
my question is is there any real harm
and clearly there is
some harm from traffic and noise
and we all know that uh parishes and
people complain
about that all the time
and it does impact on the
immunity of people's dwellings or
neighbours to animals
but i have to ask myself whether if we
do provide parking the passing spaces on
on the road at the access road
have we not resolved that issue
and we are left with what is a
relatively
small number of vehicles
um transiting to the site on a few days
a year
plus as i think has been pointed out by
others um
vehicles that might be used by the
actual business operators which will not
be transitioning on a day-to-day basis
so i guess on balance i find
although i feel that
supporting
the businesses that are not viable is
not good for our local economy
there isn't any great harming this
application and i'm prepared to support
it thank you thanks counselor mayor then
council pastor
thanks sir um
i fully support my colleagues on the
back road here and i'm not going to
reiterate things they've already said um
i would like to pick up a couple of
things um the council of field said i'm
not sure i'm a judge
or should be judging whether a business
is viable or not that is nothing to do
with me and i don't think anything to do
with what we're doing here today um we
are plan driven and that's the important
thing it's not what we like or dislike
we're trying to apply plans
and the traffic
well
suffolk county council has said that
the passing places they have no comments
other than passing places are required
and the impact traffic is not severe and
my understanding is that we cannot
reject a planning application unless
traffic
causes a severe impact
it obviously doesn't here so traffic
actually is not a relevant
consideration for us today
i'd also point out that threshing field
parish council have a fully formed
neighborhood plan
that is a plan of which we should take
due note and give due wait
they are supportive of this application
and policies within that plan
should therefore be noted
i understand where metfield parish
council and mendon parish council are
coming from
but sadly they do not have a
neighborhood plan
therefore i must give more weight to the
plan that exists
so perhaps that's something they may um
like to commutate on in the future
um
i'm fully supportive of this and will be
voting for thank you thank you
councillor passmore um thank you
chairman just i really want to be very
very clear um on page i think it's 31
where it says going back to this parking
place we just need to make sure is
parking places um should permission be
given ahead because i think that is
absolutely fundamental i don't want to
reiterate what other people have said i
would also just like to make the the
comment when i was talking about the
colors of the glamping pods it's not
that there is anything wrong with that
per se what i was
attempting to try and explain perhaps at
the wrong time if one goes ahead 20 30
years
and say something happened the
landscaping changes very important we
maintain the landscaping so that it
doesn't become garish in the future
because you don't know who's going to
earn something in 10 15 20 30 years time
and we always have to look at the
long-term consequences of things like
this so that's really what i was trying
to say
and i clearly didn't phrase it in the
right way as a question but that that
was my concern um just so everybody
knows so it's just those comments if we
can make sure that these parking places
are very very clearly put down in any
conditions that should people vote for
this thank you thank you councilman
thank you yeah i think um when we
discussed this previously i did mention
that i had been to an event at wakelings
um a couple of years ago
and i hadn't actually mentioned that so
far i think we probably need to just
note it
um having said that i won't repeat
what's already been said i i think that
viability can be
can be an an issue for us as a planning
committee
um
i i think that
it is it is secondary in this case to
the various benefits that it that it
brings to the economy
and um
one i mean if one was
finally balanced and if we're not as it
seems so far if we were finally balanced
we might be saying well um we will give
this three years to see if it works i
can remember having done that years ago
to to a mobile home and then if the
mobile home proves the business is
viable then
permission for for on-site etc dwelling
so things like that
but we're not in that place the
committee are largely um
or entirely so far
in support and and i i agree with that
thank you
thank you i guess i'm the only one that
hasn't spoken um
i mean for me there's
there's a conflict here that's that's
that's my biggest problem so we've got a
planning application uh for change of
use so part of the land for 12 glamping
pods and six mobile homes and retention
and part of the farm building create
educational baking city i have
absolutely no problem with that at all
the problem i have
is what i know is a periphery
activity that is not part of the
planning application but is being tied
into a 106
which is beneficial that it is being
tied in
and it's it's trying to and and it's i
think really for the majority of the
residents
my inclination is it's not this 12
clamping pods and six mobile homes is
causing really the conflict for them
either it's the larger events when they
see the larger number of vehicles go up
and down the lane so how has that
transpired well i agree uh
well done to the case officer for
working to pull together to pull it all
into one
um
i i think the applicant is has stated
very clearly he's very well aware of the
local concerns in the community the
24-hour contact number the fact there'll
be parking places will reduce the
the damage hopefully to the neighbors
who have seen their people driving up on
their land
so um
and of course actually the applicant can
hold 56 events a year anyway without any
of this so so it is a conflict that
causes me difficulty but actually if i
look at the bigger picture with the 106
tied in i think it will be better for
the residents than it could be without
having this so it's on that basis that i
find like i will support this because i
have absolutely no problem with the the
actual application itself it's the 106
that i think is actually probably going
to bring greater benefit in the long run
for the neighbours
uh so
phil you wanted to come in before we go
to a vote
thank you chairman yes um
two points and having listened to debate
and having seen things emerged since our
papers are printed as you'll see on page
item uh
eight f of the section 106
recommendation is for community parish
notification stroke advertisement of
upcoming events
having thought about this and being
alive to the fact from my own experience
mr pearce has his i have mine mine comes
from the world of aviation
um
it makes a huge amount of sense to see
whether we can broker more knowledge in
a more formal way between the parish
councils here
and what i'd like to suggest chairman uh
and this is for the propulsion secondary
to consider
is to expand f
to
uh include measures for the
establishment of a community liaison
group which includes one representative
each of the applicants freshing field
parish council metfield parish council
menden parish council mid suffolk
chaired by the world member
that to me would build the opportunity
for dialogue around these activities as
you describe
if that
liaison group on a met on a regular
basis and my suggestion just to start
with would be quarterly to review
upcoming events and to deal with playing
issues that might have arisen in the
course of previous events
and then to report those to the planning
authority should there be any issues
which are considered to be of concern
that chairman would seem to me to build
confidence and trust for the long term
obviously you also talked earlier about
the question of what council might do in
dealing with section 106s
and i would suggest as a corollary to
that
that we add a little o to the
recommendation which is cost recovery
associated with
uh effectively participating in that
group on the part of the council's
offices and uh in monitoring compliance
of the section 106 and that's not
unusual these days
so i do have two suggestions which might
build increased trust and confidence
around those matters um and that's where
i'll leave it chairman thanks i mean i
mean um councillor field is the absolute
expert in liaison groups in this council
uh having uh
carried the great blakeland energy for
waste site liaison group but i'll leave
it to others uh councillor
e burning councillor
yeah you're happy with that are you
happy with that well
i yes and no in that i wouldn't want you
know
there's obviously been some kind of
um
let's say bad feeling that's been
generated around this application and i
wouldn't want there to be some kind of
liaison
group where
the parish councils think that if they
complain about something then that's
immediately going to be change
everything or whatever else and it and
and i think it's quite
you know and equally not for the
applicant to think that you know if they
want to do something oh i've got to get
the approval of the of the liaison group
i mean it needs to be a a um
a collaborative kind of or an
information sharing not not a kind of
mini court of law process for complaints
kind of thing so
um if it's purely on information sharing
then then fine and i think no no
more frequent and quarterly i think
otherwise that's onerous and
think
time limit for the first
you know you don't want it forever put
it in for the for the first couple of
years and and
something like that
yeah thank you mr i agree and um yeah
it's an informative group um otherwise
you have this battle at every meet do
you well now i've got so we're not going
to go down that route it's informative
and i think you're right with the time
couple yes yeah
and
around the cost recovery which is
standard yeah okay um happy to go to a
vote council madison yeah yeah i just
wondered whether um you know is it
clearly the it's these larger events
that are the cause of the community
concern overwhelmingly and all right
you know other other things have been
have been you know sort of added on to
to try and knock the thing down but um
whether officers have got anything else
to say about the
the
the district council's role in managing
larger events
um beyond what's what's already been
said particularly i think i think if you
look through the recommendations that's
the reassurance that i think people need
if you look under bullet point eight
there is a lot listed there do you want
to come in phillip
yes jim just before you do proceed to
vote it will be useful i think just to
go through precisely what is being put
to members of the proposal because
obviously mr vincent
mr pierce mentioned some additional
items at the beginning we've obviously
tweaked things slightly so i think for
clarity it would just be useful to
switch that's right would you like to
lead off or thank you
so um i've suggested and i believe the
proposer and second seconder have agreed
and we've reached a point where um for a
period i think of two years was in
discussion
that uh item f of uh the section 106
uh
community parish notification
advertisement of upcoming events
shall include measures for the
establishment of a community liaison
group which shall include one
represented each of the applicant
threshingfield parish council metfield
parish council member parish council in
mid suffolk and which shall be chaired
by the ward member liaison group to meet
uh with the afghan not less than
quarterly and to review upcoming events
and planning issues which may have
arisen in the course of events
and in relation to this permission and
to report to the lpa any relevant
matters regarding the permission and the
purpose of this section 106 to
corporately safeguard community
engagement so that runs for a period of
two years and then a little o
uh which would be cost recovery arising
from the reasonable cost of the local
planning authority and monitoring
compliance with this section 106 and him
participating in the liaison group under
f
so that's amendments to the
recommendation one the section 106
and then to the passing places
to include
a provision um
p which is uh passing places to be
agreed and dedicated to highway usage
because you can't do that under planning
conditions so we need to make sure that
those places are available are kept
available for uh highway users of all
nature and to include that as as an
additional uh section 106
and then
mr pearce added various other elements
which i think he's done some
housekeeping i'll hand over to him
thank you
first was to require additional parking
plans to be submitted detailed parking
plans
details of
landscape reinforcement works and the
removal of temporary use pd within the
redline site
and that sits on top of everything on
page 31 and page 32 of your papers
good point thank you
councilman to make it clear that we're
talking about rural workers
thank you
okay on that basis uh proposed by
a councillor e burns second and it has
been seconded
here on my left as well are we gonna
you're gonna type that all in
no
the second if i can't are you just gonna
put seconds by cancel humphreys if i
read the vote for you okay
your
number
dc2101735 be approved as detailed in the
office of the recommendation contained
in the presentation to committee and the
additional conditions and updated s106
agreement as read out by the chief
planning officer and the case officer
okay
that's now in progress
four thank you council humphreys
uh
you chair that's eight votes for that's
unanimous okay
thank you very much okay so what we're
going to do is we're going to start
again by 11 45 at this clock on the next
agenda item 7b so that some people can
leave and some new people can come in
and just grab a cuppa quickly and start
at course two please
okay welcome back everyone so now i'm
going to move straight on to application
number dc2103292
uh in backton
and we're going to hand over to john
paintman g who's going to take us
through this item john
thank you
get these the right way around
so this is
an application for 85 dwellings 30 of
which would be affordable
this includes vehicular access for birch
avenue open space provision
community
facility provision in in terms of use
soft landscaping
and attenuation basin and all the
relevant associated sustainable drainage
bacton itself just to kind of find where
we are here we are photograph
and we zoom in we are south of the
settlement boundary and south of the
main
form of development for well there's
sort of a cluster of
bagdan
we have
a railway line to the eastern boundary
with mature trees to the uh western
boundary and moorfield to the south and
of course the developed existing estate
to the north
i think it'd be helpful to the public
watching on youtube etc if we had the
right heading up there i can't imagine
how
how it's the wrong one but it is the old
the previous one oh well done thank you
excellent
[Laughter]
thank you right so we just to clarify we
are safe south of burch avenue uh
backton and if i take the mouse
uh by birch avenue we mean this road
coming down here uh this is pritiman
avenue going along here and around
right
so this is the official redline plan
and when we have the constraints the
size itself doesn't really have any
specific designations or constraints you
will notice though there is a public
right-of-way that crosses the railway
line and then comes across this corner
of the site here which when you look at
the layout plans it has been taken into
account
obviously wider afield we've got the
settlement boundary of bacton itself
coming around here and around here
and we you can see the various little
green lines of public rights away that
are dotted around
there are listed buildings of course
most of these are
over here
just sort of colored either green or
orange going off to the left
so this is a full application
this means that
layout scale access appearance
principle landscaping all of that
everything is before us
there is an outline applications an
outline application was granted in june
so just last year
and this is essentially an outline for
the same development for 85 houses and
with reserve matters except for access
access was part of that outline
application
the access
for that outline application was
approved in two locations uh it was
approved here to connect through on this
point in terms of vehicular access and
vehicle access was approved in this
location as well
this application is a full application
not
the probably the expected reserve
matters that you would expect to come
later after the outline the reason a
full application has come forward is
simply because
of a change in the redline plan to allow
for one access
and not both vehicular
so
because of that change they put a full
application in for the whole thing
and that's what is before us
so
in our opinion as officers it is
reasonable you know again in our opinion
to give
the outline permission some significant
weight
as a material consideration in this
regard
so
we also feel that the applicant has
considered the outline and what was
approved at that time and the protection
of amenity uh the distances from
buildings to the rear of properties has
been continued into the application
before us as well
the actual access to uh wrong mouse i
keep doing that
this one
the actual access here is pedestrian
access now only and
you know a bit of open space and
greenery has been put into there so
we've got a new place and a new
connection uh but not for vehicular
access
and the actual access for the entire
development will come through here uh
there's more detailed plans later
and essentially
this will lead to the community center
however that may look in the future here
this proposal only provides land for the
community centre the details of what the
building
whatever it might be looks like it will
be a matter of a separate application
we have parking for that
and a green space here but as we lead
through this now leads through to the
rest of the
proposal the 85 houses and we have the
open sort of the
sustainable drainage
off here to the
west
i should note at this point that part of
the land
here
is known as the hills i believe locally
it's a little area of open space
that is owned by mid-suffolk district
council
obviously that is not a planning matter
the ownership is a private legal one
between the council as landowner and the
applicant
but it would be for due diligence and
transparency
just to mention that at this point
and what i will now hopefully do get the
right one
is
just go through the various plans
so we have obviously the developed area
and the
various plans that you would have had in
your packs
showing the
parking showing where the height levels
will be
and so forth
this is the location of the affordable
housing
and we have landscape plans as well
obviously on the powerpoint the detail
of that isn't going to be able to clear
but
essentially
we are looking to create a new landscape
boundary on the southern side majority
of that is obviously open at the moment
but allowing some sites through
uh to be maintained
uh we also have the existing
mature
tree line here which is going to be
maintained
there is a degree of what you can do
with a railway line
on one side
not least from the point of view of
making sure that the railway line itself
doesn't have any maintenance issues if
you suddenly put a lot a lot of trees
against that but
there's a little bit there as well
that's more details around the actual
access now proposed
to ensure that that's compliant with
safety and highway requirements
and then we have the proposal
now i've reduced the presentation down
to essentially
some street elevations because we have
all of the different types and there's a
lot of them
in your packs if you
obviously have a chance to look at those
there's a range of housing types there
are bungalows
as shown there
a fairly wide range of materials very
wide range of styles
and we have individuals there like the
bungalow
they come with brick glimpse and and
fairly detailed design
and uh bay features and so forth so good
range
and i'll just skip through those a
little bit
leading on to the photos right
so
this is
looking uh from the end of birch avenue
we've got the area known as the hills
just over on the right i believe and
there is a bungalow here on the left
the existing bungalow and of course
looking at it the other way around now
standing on the area known as the hills
and looking at the existing estate
and trying to give you a sense of that
area as a new access through
to the field as you can see we're now in
the field that's subject to the
application it's very difficult to give
you photographs that make sense in once
because
you just get lost in a big field
but
just to give you a sense
there's no denying it is open to the
south so it is quite an open sight at
this current time
and just to give you a sense of looking
back to the estate
and what you see at the moment
and just doing a probably sort of
standing in the corner looking around
the whole site and then beyond the site
to the south
the railway line is
sunken to a degree
because there is a bridge that crosses
over that from a a complete right away
point of view
so the bridge is somewhere just here
somewhere going across or crossing so it
should say
it's not a bridge sorry just crossing
across there
it wasn't a bridgeway
there is a football ground on the other
side yes
a bridge is that level so in my episode
unfortunately i'm not the case officer
so it looked like which on the
photographs apologies um the offer
ultimately yes there is current access
requirements across that point to the
football ground
i would imagine people from the existing
estate go across there that way
all dwellings comply with accessible and
adaptable dwelling standards all
affordable houses will comply with the
internal space standards are set out in
the national describe space standards
all dwellings have private enclosed
garden spaces
they have on plot or close by allocated
parking there are garages proposed for
21 plots
the scheme has been informed by
sustainable
considerations this includes air source
heat pumps to every dwelling
and
a1 green rated materials
water efficiency fittings electric
vehicle charging to all dwellings
on plot parking spaces as well
we also have adaptable internal spaces
to allow for home working and obviously
that has a greater importance in perhaps
the last couple of years
given the outline and its fallback it is
reasonable to say we've established the
principle of development
and the recommendation before members
reflects this the obligations secured
under the outline application are again
sought in this case because obviously
this is a full application in its own
right
the development is considered to be in
keeping with the adjacent development in
terms of scale density with suitable
appearance
there was a good amount of practical
open space green space and space for
trees to grow
and to add to the attraction of the site
over the time
importantly there was new opportunity
for community activity to find a focal
point on this site engaging both
existing and the future community
as a whole and therefore in collusion
the recommendation is one of approval
thank you very much
yes lots of questions going on cancer
mayor first
thanks chuck um can you tell us more
about the access i'm a little confused
we're going down from two access roads
to one
is the reason for that reduction
um
obviously the outline means the fallback
is they could go back to the two if they
wanted to um there there's no reason in
planning terms y2 isn't uh
acceptable because we've granted it here
we go um
i don't know the reason specifically why
this application has come i think there
is there's more to it and the ward
member can probably when we come to him
can elaborate on that for us an
associated question then um
is there a second access for emergency
vehicles
so you can go up to 150 houses without
needing a secondary access
um so
but on the other hand the the
pedestrianized route
is going to be open so if absolutely
necessary you could you could probably
get through there
across that point
and
a different question now am i writing
reading that the outline
um
approval
had
bungalows along the northern boundary
and that in this full application those
bungalows some of those have turned into
um
two-story houses
you look confused why are you really
wrong
sorry
the application is full so everything is
before you for this application so it is
a case of your judgment of whether you
feel that the estate design now proposed
is suitable or not
council
uh thank you chairman and just a
question if i may regarding flooding i'm
slightly confused by the evidence we've
got there's a holding objection i think
from the county council flood people um
can you just explain how that works for
the applicant i'm sure they can resolve
it but one of the things i've always
found slightly odd although this i don't
think is in a flood plain or anywhere
near it
one thing that might help of course is
when we get torrential rain is not to
have too many impermeable driveways and
so on so in other words the water could
percolate through now i don't know um
whether that's appropriate this or not
but i'm slightly puzzled by this holding
um position regarding fluttering i think
it's on page 148 149.
what what does that actually mean
john can you come in yeah i'm sorry to
bounce it here i know it's a very
specific question i spot out drums had
to pick this up because the case officer
couldn't be here today so that's why
john may not have all the detail to hand
straight away i understand that i
understand the flood team are satisfied
i've just got to find the response that
says that so bear with me um so the
holding objection is on there but
there's not an updated
was there an updated one in
in these days where you can get some
torrential downpours obviously dealing
with surface water not going into an
angry and water asset i think it says
earlier in there how they would just
resolve it i'm not wishing the whole the
discussion i'll answer the details of
that but i i've got here my notes from
the case officer that the sub scheme is
now fully approved by
the suffolk county council's uh flood
team so uh i'm guessing there must be an
amended correspondence right i can try
and chase that yeah
later thank you
uh counts uh e burn
um thank you very much chair um
i've got several questions if i may but
firstly on page 105 of our report um
can we just correct that the nhs england
comment says that sill has been
requested to increase capacity at the
backton branch of mendelssohn's surgery
it hasn't work is underway at
mendelssohn's surgery to increase
capacity there and bacton happens to be
the branch of membership server surgery
as far as i'm aware there's no work
going on at backton branch and i think
actually when you read their specific
comment that does explain that it's just
been put in the report incorrectly at
the top of that page um there the parish
council has said to seek confirmation
that dwellings 78 81 and 82 a single
story can you just show me on the map
where they were because i couldn't see
that um on
the the i mean i probably could have
found it online but i couldn't find it
in the papers
yeah so there should be um
do you have color on your pack in terms
of this is that is that the ones backing
on to the
existing yeah so there's an orange line
that says everything needed to be
because one of the things in the outline
was that there should only be a single
story uh at a certain point um so
that should be followed through in terms
of this application if you bear with me
i'll just find the right plan
i'll try and put it on screen is that
that slide tens that i think
so
where is the orange line there with me
[Applause]
right so if i can put is it slide 11 on
the screen possibly thank you
i'll go find it
i've got good photographs
i am sure there's probably a quicker way
of doing this but bear with me
right
now the one i want is
another one that one
so um
the orange houses are the single story
so so 78 81 and 82. i presume those ones
those three are they then the three blue
ones um
backing onto
prettyman avenue those three those three
would be two-story well
so those those are the ones i can't see
them read the numbers that's all i'm
assuming those are then 78 8182
but
uh bear with me so i can read them on
here
yeah
okay
i can't read the plot numbers on my
version okay
thank you and my um
two two more questions if i may one is
the affordable seem to be in two great
big chunks and one is beautifully
sighted right next to the railway line
um
i just wonder if there's been any more
discussion about
why have we ended up with two chunks
and backing onto the railway on one of
them
and secondly
could you tell me what the depth of the
hedge landscaping is
along the boundary between the new homes
and the existing ones on prettyman
avenue please
all right
the
first answer to the question is why is
the affordable housing uh in in lumped
obviously there is a balance with
spreading affordable housing out in
terms of pepper potting's absolute
phrases
called versus what housing associations
want which is housing cluster together
for ease of maintenance and
and and dealing with the land transfer
uh concerns so it is a matter of that
balance i'm not aware of any objection
uh to what's proposed from one housing
team thank you but um i'll leave that
there
in terms of the hedgerow i'd have to
come back to you and check the file if
that's okay so this is on the which
boundary sorry it's it's on the boundary
of the existing
the gardens of the existing homes on
pretty man avenue and the new home so on
the northern
um
section of the site please and there's
there's a landscape
hedging which i think is going to be
looked after by a management committee
but
i just
there's obviously been concerned about
that that and i want to know how deep
that
how wide or deep whatever is that i'll
get in and measure it in just a moment
thank you that's the answer
uh thank you chair i uh i've got uh four
queries that i would just like to ask um
i i miss some of the conversation that
you were having with councillor matheson
about the bridge um is there a bridge
over the railway or is it a crossing
that is likely to be shut by a national
rail due in due course that my second
question is can you you rushed over a
whole list of things that the applicant
was doing
um and i think you said that they were
all to national space standards but
there was a comment in the papers about
that not being made clear so can i just
clarify that
third question is about cycle links
the access that was to be a road access
that's now only going to be pedestrian
is that also going to be a cycle link
and is there also a cycle link that
looks it looks like it might be um there
on the sort of uh north western corner
onto a track uh one of the plans i can
see says something about cycle link
um and the other one is there's a
residence representation
comment about planting on the southern
boundary um so what is the planting on
the southern boundary thank you
apologies for reference to the bridge is
a crossing not a bridge
so in terms of the railway line it's not
a bridge
so that deals with that um the
cycle link
it doesn't appear to be it's not
confirmed to be a cycle link so
[Music]
um that would be something for you to
debate
planting again i have to go back to
look up those planting issues and i can
come back to you both on that in a
moment
and the national space
national space requirements do apply to
the affordable housing
i don't think they apply entirely to the
market housing but we you can take that
further
can i come back on the on the cycle link
um i've got a plan off the um
off the website thing
which quite clearly says
cycle link in the west northwestern
corner of the site
uh that's not the access onto pritaman
lane it's access onto what i believe is
a track
uh but should i be asking the applicant
about those things
i think to ask the applicant for
confirmation and this is where i we have
to apologize that i'm not the case
officer and i haven't worked on this for
months
i'm only presenting what is given to me
um ultimately uh we can for the
avoidance of doubt take that away if
necessary as
if you were to say debate
and you're only going to approve it
because of it being a cycle way then
that's something we would adjust in
terms of your recommendation just to
make sure that cycleway is achieved in
in that context but i'll come back to
you on that as well
we're adding to your comeback list
aren't we counselor matheson
thank you um yeah i should have spotted
perhaps at the beginning of the of the
meeting that i've
i was on the site visit that went
to here
prior to being on the committee which
granted the outline permission um so i i
do know
that
we
the several things that came from that
work first one of which was it was the
question about the the the access the
change of access well originally the
access was entirely prettyman avenue and
when we got there we said who's is that
bit of land there and it's old mid
suffix now and right so then we said
well we must
surely use that as the the entrance
because the the community locally was
not happy with the prettyman
uh avenue entrance to the site
so um
we then moved to two entrances and then
we've come back we've now got the
preferred entrance so that that's where
that came from and clearly again the the
bungalows that
that back onto this site
we we wanted to to
reduce the impact by putting some there
and that's why you've got the amount of
of space and the single story
specified that we've seen
and um there was one other point that i
think came out of that
um
there might have been another one but
anyway so the the
that's why things are are now as as they
are to some extent and obviously that's
why i knew there was nothing so we were
just on quest the bridge yeah the bridge
the bridge was the so what's the
question
right the question the question that i
have is quite separate to those points i
just wanted to explain why you know i
don't need we're not in debates we're in
questions of the presentation right yet
now the question is the sustainability
statement
we've got
page 106 the reference says condition
recommended for sustainability and
energy scheme but actually
um
the
the sustainability statement has been
it's been submitted and on page 179
um we seem to be reading that the
the sustainability officer has actually
looked at it and is he's happy with it
so there's there's a bit of a mismatch
there so do we need a condition
when the the conditions already been
signed off i think is essentially
the question
but i didn't get an answer so i've got
to ask it again here uh yes to ensure
that the measures are implemented
so we may haven't
you can proposed that under debate
thank you
any councilfield a question
wouldn't you like a life history
question the question is uh the section
obligation includes um open space
delivery and management in perpetuity
the question is basically um understand
the question do we
in those 106s do anything to control
that any management charges associated
with such management activity
are fair and reasonable and escalate at
a
reasonable rate i guess
ie inflation or something around there
do we make any action because
i suppose the the life history bit is
that i do have
an area at the moment where the
escalation seems to be anything but
reasonable
ultimately the um the detail of this is
to provide open space that would be for
the public access
um
then the 106 would
also seek details of the um
a locally equipped area of play
and so essentially what the 106 is doing
is in securing the provision of that
space
the long-term maintenance is a matter of
we are going to ask for it to be
maintained and it's likely to be either
a private management company
unless
someone like the parish or someone else
steps forward
there is no provision in normally
set in motion in standard terms of any
money in that context
so
that is not provided for
um
ultimately
when we as a council take over land
we negotiate for a sum of money
[Music]
from the developer because we want it to
be maintained for a good 10 years or so
obviously in this context if it's the
parish council they may say well we'll
take it off your hands but we want
funds of x to be able to maintain it for
at least 10 years
or the and this is probably why private
management company is popular choice
because essentially
it takes revenue from the new houses as
a yearly tariff or something
and ultimately
maintains all open spaces
in that form
apply a tariff to those houses that
escalates dramatically
to the disadvantage particularly those
perhaps in affordable dwellings do we
achieve any level of control or is that
not appropriate no because i would
imagine that when you buy a house that's
the point you
negotiate or decide whether or not
you're signing up to that or not and
that's uh a market yeah that's that goes
through the legal pack you get when you
look at the property i think
uh i've got
that's it from questions
okay i think it was touched on already
but i wasn't wasn't
clear that the
2.4 in in in the report the um
nationally described space standards um
is it then the case that the
the market homes are are not
um compliant with with ndss
if you read the sentence carefully
it it says that the
the affordables will be i'll let the
agent tell me otherwise but i don't
believe they are entirely compliant no
um can i come back on those other points
though that were raised earlier so
in respect of
um the
cycle links first of all so we have a
three meter cycle lane or link that goes
around the attenuation basin on the
north
west side
we don't have on the plan i have before
me any indication of
the link to britainman avenue also being
a cycle link but saying that
it's wider than the cycle link that goes
around the attenuation
so
i would imagine there would be no harm
saying that needs to think it should be
both cycle and pedestrian
the buffer to the north boundary the
landscape buffer that goes at the back
of the properties and this is at the
back of plots one to six and then also
78 through to
that landscape buffer on my measurement
here is almost five meters wide
uh the southern
boundary buffer
if you give me a moment
it is
there's a green uh space there's
obviously a way you can walk around the
southern boundary because there's a
pedestrian path there
the green space between that path and
the edge of the boundary is about four
and a half meters
within that
planting of trees in clusters will be
proposed but it isn't solid
effect thank you for that um john i i'm
just pondering this cycle link and i i'm
sorry that we've had a lot of papers and
i'm not overfilled exactly where i need
to be looking
um
the three meter cycle link on the
northwestern corner
of the of the site
uh which is sort of on the northern edge
of the attenuation basin on a plan i've
found online i'm not sure if it's in the
pack
uh it looks like it goes outside of the
red line area
so
is that part of the section 106 and on
some of the other plans it appears to
wrap around a bit further around the
attenuation basin with before going out
to the track so it seems to be a bit of
inconsistency about where it's going
i believe on the north west connection
there was a claimed right of way to get
to the between the site and the track
and that's all i know
okay
right
thank you for that so we're going to
move on uh councilman you have a
question before we go on to the speakers
i'm not signed in here oh well thank you
right thank you chair
um yeah just a couple of questions um
the question on the buffer at the north
boundary because i know this is a real
concern for residents of the existing
homes there
is that buffer um back fence to back
fence
of the gardens or is it within the
gardens of the new properties
so that's the first question
according to the plan i have in front of
me it appears to be within the garden if
i take the way they are drawn
so the majority of it is
in the garden so the reason for the
question is because some of the
residents on that um
boundary the sort of existing southern
bit of the estate have rights of access
to the back of their gardens and there's
a path there so i really wouldn't want
that to be compromised by whatever we do
here that's also shown on here so the
right of access is maintained by the
looks of the gap between the two
boundaries okay thank you another
question is on the player
in in the papers it says that there's
provision for
um
land for a play area
i'm pretty sure normally with these sort
of applications you know the play area
comes fully kitted out so i'm not quite
sure why that's not the case
here
um in my experience we have both
approaches really we've seen
applications even as a full application
with a complete understanding of whether
it's uh you know are they talk springing
tortoises and everything else and
climbing frames
in this case we have provision for it
and we have it in the 106 to achieve the
specification that's the important thing
for it so that is
push down the line a bit for agreement
later
something for us to debate later for you
to bring up later
okay thank you so we're going to move on
to the speakers now we have no one from
the parish council we have no objector
no supporter
but we have the applicant david fletcher
so over to you and you have three
minutes please
thank you chairman um
if i say we fully endorse the officer's
recommendation um i set out in the
report um beltway homes acquired this
site um following the grant of the
outlying uh approval that was mentioned
by your planning officer and just to
clarify the point about the the access
uh the normal course of action would
have been for us to submit a reserve
matters application on the back of that
outline approval
however the birch avenue
access provided solely access to the
community centre not to the residential
dwellings
as part of our very early
pre-application discussions it became
very clear that there was significant
concern
both from the parish council
local ward members and also residents
within the local area particularly along
prettyman avenue regarding the access
point from pritiman avenue
we like to think this is a really good
example actually where a developer has
listened to those concerns and rather
than submitting a reserve matters
application which would have been the
most straightforward it would have
negated the need for us
to do a new section 106 agreement and
and further background reports
we took the view of submitting a full
planning application to reconfigure the
access from um birch avenue to allow all
of the traffic to be served from birch
avenue and to avoid
traffic having to go down prettyman
avenue
which is a fairly narrow cul-de-sac um
just just to pick up on some other key
principles from the
uh from the outline application um we
fully fully honored that that what was
it was a 20 meter separation distance to
the to the dwellings on prettyman avenue
so all wanting to set at least 20 meters
back from that and the majority along
that that boundary at bungalows as we've
heard we're also providing a landscape
buffer
and and we've relocated the pump station
which was agreed as part of the outline
application
in addition we've also heard that the
the residential properties along
pritiman avenue
will have right of access to the south
so they can access their rear gardens
again as we've heard from your case
officer we're fully committed to
sustainable design
and we are providing all dwellings with
air source heat pumps and all dwellings
with electric vehicle charging points
we've also adopted a fabric first
approach where we are achieving
significant improvements
um above
building regulation standards
the dwellings have been designed to
reflect and respond to the traditional
character and appearance of the
surrounding area and we will believe we
believe this development will make a
positive contribution to the area uh
just to pick up quickly on the the lead
local flood authority point that their
their point of concern solely in
relation to maintenance and management
and i think as as we've heard that's
been picked up as part of the section
um
section 106 agreement um
we're very happy to answer any questions
that the members will have and i suspect
there may want to be one or two and just
as i've got lawrence briggs with me
today from from belway homes who is also
on hand and happy to answer um any
questions and and lastly in that regard
just just note that backton parish
council supporting um
this application and i think that that's
largely reflected the discussions we've
had with them and and the change that
we've made in terms of the access point
location along with other matters thank
you thank you very much
yeah questions go start the end
counsellor manson then even
uh thank you um
first of all i'd like to ask um
about the um a bit of clarity about the
national space standards on the market
homes can you clarify whether or not all
of the market houses are to those
standards i'd also like your um your
comment on
the um
issue raised by one of our um housing
whatever it is whatever the term is um
officers about
the
small number of open market
two-bedroomed homes which um doesn't
meet the requirements uh for housing in
mid-south i know it's not policy but i
just like your comment on it
and also
are you able to uh clarify the position
about the cycle link on the northwestern
corner and where it actually goes
because i've got plans of two different
places and are you would you be happy if
that access and the access onto pretty
much avenue were to be cycle links as
well as pedestrian links thank you
yeah but that that that's fine no i'll
i'll i'll do my best and i think i'll
also just say my
my colleague seth patel who's been
dealing with this date today he's on
paternity leave at the moment hence why
while i might need to bring in laura to
um answer any of the questions but
firstly regarding uh nationally
described space standards i confirm that
nearly all of the private dwellings meet
that standard all of the dwellings meet
m42 standards across the whole site and
nearly all the dwellings are ndss um
compliant um
as well
um i think the the um there was a
question regarding cycle link provision
um yeah it's fully it's our intention
there's a cycle link provided both in
that northwest corner of the site and
also
um north ontario avenue um and if if
there needs to be any wording to that
effect in terms of planning condition to
secure it that that's um absolutely fine
um from our
um
from our perspective
sorry
can you just
the the other question was about
the limited number of two-bedroom market
dwellings and whilst i've just got my
mic on uh you say nearly all of them
meet the standards could you tell me how
many don't
lord shawna do you want to come in
yeah
so in your question regarding um
the two bed units
so we have uh four joiners um which are
two beds we also have three wood carver
bungalows which are two beds that could
be four
and they're m42 compliant as well and we
we don't have any uh further market
dwellings at two beds we do have a small
three bed um dwellings which are the
tailors
that that's the name of the property
yeah
so yeah we have um so we don't have any
further two beds but we do have a very
small tailor which are which is a
three-bed unit
and are they the ones that don't meet
the national space standards oh no sorry
i was just confirming what was the two
bed and what was the three bed
um
so the space standards i don't believe
that plot 78 the space nationals
describe space standard because that is
a uh saffron
but i believe all the other ones today
one property doesn't meet the standards
is that what you're telling me
one design is that
it's this
78 suffolk plot 78 78
okay i've got councillor ebern next
um thank you very much chair um thank
you for your um
comments so far
um i've got several questions if i may
um
firstly the uh landscape buffer between
the development and print and the um
gardens of freshman avenue um
would you be
um if we conditioned that to be five to
six meters wide
um
to ensure that that is actually a um
a buffer and also what what's to kind of
prevent people from moving in finding
they've got a massive hedge at the end
of their garden and thinking oh well i'd
rather have another five meters of
garden so i'll
so will that be maintained by a
management company so can we firstly
five to six meters and second year
management company
um i was also going to ask about the
housing mix but my colleague has done
that thank you um and
the um
with regards to the bungalows along the
[Music]
back onto that there were three plots
that the parish council mentioned would
you be able to change those um
two bungalows and thirdly the
the leap you know the play area bit um
if it's in the section 106 just to be
provided where's the money coming from
to actually put one in is that going to
be within the section 106 so that there
is
you know it's all very well providing an
area and saying it's going to be there
but are you providing the the finances
to
for whoever to put that leap um
i'm she would be a leap one elite player
we're in thank you very much thank you
yeah no no problem yeah again i'll i'll
do my best um on that i think firstly
just picking up on the on the wick for
the landscape planting i think
you know very happy to have wording in a
section 106 agreement regarding that
it's just to kind of confirm it will be
part of the management companies there's
no risk of that being removed
sorry can i just interject there
oh
it wasn't okay so just interject and we
will um right into the deed of the
contract for the purchasers they're not
going to be able to remove the buffer so
and any work that they do anyway in
their deed would always come back to
beltway to approve
um
just just to pick up on the point about
the the width i would rather that wasn't
specific um in terms of agreement just
to give a flexibility as we've said
we've got this uh area to the south of
the residential dwellings where there's
there's pedestrian access to the for the
dwellings to the south of
um prettyman avenue so there's a bit of
a balance between the the the width of
that access and the landscape buffer um
certainly i mean from our perspective
our landscape plans have been drawn to
show a substantial landscape buffer and
that's not to say that we can't achieve
five to six meters but i would rather
that would be a detail that we can can
deal with by um you know with officers
and obviously we've we've heard the
comments um
today in that regard um to secondly just
to pick up on the point about the the
bungalows just to just to confirm i
believe actually on that plan two out of
three dwellings are bungalows i think
that that they were
if you look at one example i think
there's the the two that are nearest to
the uh pedestrian uh access with british
moon avenue i believe that's plot 78 and
plot 79. um i believe it's plot 82 which
is the one which is the
it's the third from the um the end is
sort of the middle point on the
uh sort of east side of the pritiman
avenue access that's the only one that
isn't but i think members will see
from that uh the the the plan that's in
front of them that that that dwelling is
is actually set the furthest back
um from prisman avenue so it is well
over the the 20 meters um
back to back distance that was
referenced
in the outline consent um and secondly
just to confirm that we we will be uh
delivering the leap and again that will
be a matter that will be secured as part
of the section 106 screen but it will be
bellway that would be responsible for
its delivery
thank you very much councillor field
thank you sorry to return to a subject
that's being brought forth of me to my
attention by some 80 residents at the
moment um the issue of the management of
the open spaces etc the management
company we've been talking about uh
clearly that's um perfectly reasonable
to hand out to a management company
i'm really just questioning your
the sort of level of control you
maintain or and that might be included
in the 106 on the
financial behavior of such companies you
know are they
they're excluded from the new government
legislation on on leaseholders as free
as its action with a freeholder
and uh clearly there's an opportunity
there not for beltway but for some
a company you might delegate to to be
unreasonable what control do you
maintain
um i take your views on board it is um
an issue that sometimes our customers
raise with us directly you know they
don't want to be um spending a certain
amount of money and then in a couple of
years time
it increases so with the management
company that we set up we try and do
reasonable and try and put reasonable
endeavors in place so they can't
exponentially put up costs and that's
written into the management company
contracts
and there'd have to be a justification
of why they were going up it you know if
there was a big issue um that they'd all
have to be um
every resident would have to be informed
of that
better not quote anything else from
there okay councilman
yeah thank you yes
that there will be a significant
biodiversity net gain and i think going
from arable fields that should be fairly
easy to um to achieve and obviously
members would be
welcoming
a big gain
um most of my other questions have been
dealt with or can you just give a
current question yeah so what i'm left
what i'm left with is is um
welcoming that the the fact that they're
all compliant with with um part m for
two
um would you be agreeable to providing
one dwelling one of the bungalows to m43
standard for so that is livable in a
with the wheelchair
as part of a planning condition um
certainly
so if it wasn't put in place as part of
the planning up planning condition that
you wanted one property to be m43 one of
the bungalows then we could certainly
look at that yeah no
thank you
okay
yeah councilman then we'll come on to
you after your question yeah so just a
couple of questions for clarification um
i'm still banging on about this northern
boundary i'm afraid um
on part of the uh
existing the back of existing houses
there's a path
um
so
are we gonna end up in a situation where
the back boundary of the existing
properties and the back fence of the new
properties are there and there's a kind
of narrow
path between them is that kind of where
we're going because i understand that
you're so i'm just trying to i'm just
going to bring in john patman g he just
wants to come in
um i don't like doing this because um
obviously i wasn't the case officer and
i wasn't involved in the negotiations at
this point but i'm kind of stepping in
here as the area planning manager a bit
um
ultimately
i'm looking at the landscape buffer that
i have on on my plan i've got this
landscape buffer i've got that is all
within the residential gardens
so each one is essentially going to be
maintained by the individual owner of
that property regardless of the covenant
or
even a 106 requirement for them to do so
you then have
the access route which is about a meter
wide
it varies slightly but effectively a
meter along there
now
i'm going to be blunt and say
that feels like a fairly unsupervised
space um in planning terms
so i am going to suggest
that
there is a solution here
but i think it's not withstanding the
plans in front of us i think would stand
notwithstanding the plans in front of us
we need to have agreement
on exactly what that landscaping buffer
is whether it should be in the gardens
or not
and the access to my mind needs a degree
of personal security with it even if
it's only available to the individuals
that use it
and i don't think that is before members
to adequately get their heads around so
i'm going to suggest
that any decision today
is either conditioned to that effect to
allow us to do that
or delegate it for us to come up with a
conclusion on that point okay thank you
well we'll pick that up
can i also also just suggest from the
from here i'm more than happy to put a
condition on the cycle link to prituman
avenue but i didn't quite understand
your point of where you said there's
different accesses for the one on the
north west they all seem to be the same
point on my plans that i've got in front
of me but
regardless of that it the the access we
the cycle way we've got only goes to the
red line boundary of the site
what happens beyond that is beyond the
control of the applicant in any event to
my knowledge um so
it reminds me actually of a site in need
a market i dealt with where we had
national uh rail involved um essentially
we can only go so far as secure up to
the point
and ironically there's still a bit of
mud between the public footpath
and that link but um they took the gate
down and people go across there anyway
but the uh the point is we can only go
so far in that context thank you
councilman you want to come back
yeah one final one i think um on page
220 of the bundle uh at the top there
this is the list of the
um
31 conditions which were put on the
outline
and and understand that belleway have um
agreed to kind of keep to the principle
of the 20 meter buffer
um between
but it says there um between 20 meters
of the northern site boundary and and i
think you said back to back so there's
just a light slight discrepancy there is
is it 20 meters back-to-back
houses or is it 20 meters from the
boundary
yes sorry that was my mistake it's 20
meters to the boundary
can i just come back because uh mr
payment g responded to my query about
the um cycle link in the northwestern
corner um
i i i'm i'm sorry the the plans in the
booklet are too small and even with a
magnifier you can't really see them so
the ones i'm looking at i've got one
that's called pl04 parking layout which
has come off your website um which has
got a loop round the top of the
attenuation basin and then the path goes
out a little way from the corner
and then i've got something that's
called pl03 detailed layout which has a
cycle link exiting right in the corner
those two are not the same place in my
mind
i believe it's the first of those the
the two so that the plo4 which is on
your parking layout thing has got it
like wrap around and then it goes sort
of out halfway down the thing that near
a tree i presume that lump is and pl03
which is called detailed layout has got
it going
straight out the corner
yeah i need to just check the rev
numbers but that yeah i think the the
first as you described is correct yeah
um thank you chair thank you let me come
back um just a quick point which has
been raised from some of the points is
this landscape buffer to the north place
services have said that
three meters isn't enough so i'm
concerned that can we put in
a
uh meterage within the discussions that
john payment g is kindly mentioned about
conditioning post the
um
any kind of decision um
to ensure that we're not left with a
very small buffer thank you
i have to come to that when we get to
debate i guess
john's got time to give it some thought
uh counselor melon uh it's now over to
you as the ward member
thank you very much chair um
so the initial outline application for
this site came before this committee a
while ago and members may recall that i
opposed the application
um at that time the site was outside the
draft jlp settlement boundary um i felt
it was a speculative application and i
had some concerns about the proposed
access
through pritchman avenue
the proposer of the site at that time
made various pledges to the community
about the size and scale of the
development and the size of the buffer
some of those were captured in the
conditions applied to that consent but i
think some of the controversy about this
current application is because those
pledges were made
um some time later the site was sold
on to belway homes and i'm happy to
report that belway have engaged
regularly and substantially with myself
as a district councillor with councillor
stringer as backtons county councillor
and also with the parish council so what
we have before you today is an
application that's gone through various
revisions
following discussions between the
developer and ourselves
the main revision and i think the reason
why this is a full application rather
than reserve matters is the change to
the access the original outline
permission had the main access coming
through the cul-de-sac off pritiman
avenue and then a secondary access
through birch avenue for emergency
vehicles and the community facility and
this was clearly problematic and i think
that the proposed single vehicular
access through birch avenue that we have
now
is a big improvement on what was
previously agreed
there are a few points i feel are worth
making the high risk department has
stated that there will not be
unacceptable or severe impacts but there
will there clearly will be some impacts
inevitably from the increased traffic
from this and the five other large
development sites coming forward
in batson
the original scheme had included
provision of off-site bus stops on pound
hill
which are not in this application though
they may be delivered through the
section 106 process
i will just point out that bacton used
to have a regular bus service coming
through from dis and i through to stone
market which has gone down to just a
minibus a couple of times a day
so i do hope that this and other
developments will
stimulate demand and we'll we will get a
better bus service in future
and and maybe the county's bus service
improvement plan will also help
i i do welcome the fact that beltway
will be heating these homes with air
source heat pumps
the original outline had a long list of
conditions number 31 of those was a
limit on the height
of homes within 20 meters of the
northern boundaries
and what people took that to mean was
there would only be bungalows on that
boundary
and that's what residents understood um
so there are however i think six
two-story homes on that boundary which
but they're just over the 20 meter limit
so i feel that bellway has kind of um
kept to the spirit of that condition
um but really not what was promised
originally so it's a shame that they're
not bungalows completely or maybe one
and a half story homes
um and the original applicant made much
of a buffer between the gardens of the
existing homes and the back fence of the
new homes there was going to be a big
strip there of open space and that has
you know disappeared and decreased down
to just the planted buffer within the
new gardens so i do hope we can sort out
something on that as john has proposed
there is concern that the layout of this
development could then lead on to a
further extension to the south
at some point in the future i know
that's not part of what we're talking
about now
but we are right next to the railway
line there is potential here
if network rail got their ducks in a row
for a new backton station with a
stopping service here and that could be
possible
so can i sum up by saying that although
i objected to the outline permission
that ship has sailed belway have really
engaged with us and the community
um
the the cycle link to pritiman avenue i
think would be very welcome
the the point councillor mansour was
making
of connecting into the track which is
called pullham's lane
i know that's outside the red line but
if we could have the potential for
connecting there that would be great
um it would be great if belway would
stomp up for the play equipment
lastly
it was mentioned that this this
access road is going through what's
called bacton hills which is some lumps
of spoil left over from previous stages
of development but they are valued by
the community because it's the only
place in the area you can slide down
when it snows so if we could somehow
recreate a slope in in the new um the
new green area that would be great but i
don't have any significant objections
beyond those points thank you chad
thank you and we applaud your optimism
for a new railway session
uh
okay any questions yes council eben
uh thank you chair thank you very much
for that i'm councillor mellon um i just
have a concern about the railway
crossing do you know by any chance of
network rail it's one of the ones that
network gonna close i can't remember off
the top of my head and um
i'm just because the
i know this area very well and across
the other side of the railways the
football ground football pitches
so
more houses here is going to be more
increased traffic
as in pedestrians going to and fro
across that um railway so um just got a
bit of a concern about the safety there
so can you just confirm what you know
there thank you
um yeah so
it's a pedestrian crossing not a vehicle
crossing and i think um
network rail have closed up a number of
the vehicular crossings but as far as i
know that one is still open it is
dangerous there's no doubt about it
although it is a straight section of
line so you can see the trains coming
but um
yeah um obviously if there was a new
station they could put a bridge
well over
uh all the questions so it's off to
discuss debate and to come to a
conclusion counselor humphrey is your
friend mr chairman thank you um
yeah there's a few things i was a little
bit concerned about but they've sort of
been
satisfied as we went through one of them
was that cluster of
the affordable houses and the fact that
they're in two clusters one close
railway line but i understand it now
that actually it's not just the
developer that's involved in this it's
the housing authorities as well and
their requirements for land
and the management of that land so i do
get it and i'm happy with that council
matthiasson confirmed actually
historically that the layout as in the
access is what they wanted and that's
what we've got and that's also been
confirmed by the ward member council
mellon so that's a good thing so i've
got an issue with the single access
either um
i like the
the keeping of the the mature hedgerow
store
trees etc my only concern with this
really is the buffer between the
properties to the north and i get the
fact that you're going to put some
planting in the garden it's really nice
you're going to condition it in deeds i
get all that but we did talk about there
was a buffer anyway because there's
access to the back of the houses on the
north isn't there so there's also a
physical buffer between the fence lines
um i'd like to see if i was going to
support this which i think i am i'd like
to see some condition that actually laid
down the dimensions of that which would
increase the buffer between the
properties
and make it
not such a tight alleyway with all the
issues they have as well in in the lives
we leave in this modern world so i'd
like to see some condition if that's
possible on the dimensions of it um i
like all the environmental stuff i like
the fact you're going for the the
air sourced heat pumps the way you're
constructing the build and everything
else electrical charging points ticks
all the right boxes the two-story houses
uh that are opposite the houses the
current uh houses in the north um i had
a an issue with that initially but as
it's been explained they are quite set
back in all fairness and there's only
three of them and one of them is well
over 20 meters
and the fact is they do satisfy the
condition which was 20 meters whether
that's 20 and a half or 21 makes the
odds it satisfies the requirement um so
i have an issue with that and and i i
will be supporting this i will listen to
other debate but i'm minded to see yeah
to propose if i will uh why come back
i'm going to propose approval um but i
would like to see that condition so john
can you just elaborate on how you would
deal with that condition please
yes i've been thinking about this a
little bit uh bearing in mind other
comments as well um
if i did as a i did say delegate or
condition if i did it as a condition i
think we can do it as a condition um
i've got my word in my head of something
like this which is not withstanding the
details received plans for the landscape
buffer along the northern boundary
shall be submitted to us for agreement
it shall achieve up to five metres where
possible now i notice we can't say five
meters across the whole lot because some
of the plots are closer than the others
so there's some provision in some that i
think are definitely worthy of five
meters a couple if you
say five meters actually takes up almost
half the garden or more so we need that
flexibility um in in the in the
conversation to have but it certainly
could be more than what it is currently
um
and this would include detailed access
arrangements
um
for the residents
as well and thereafter those
details should be retained as agreed
including its management so
we can do that and we can put a
condition to that effect
but we i think i think we uh we
apologize at this point because i think
that area we could have sounded out a
bit better than what we have done up to
this point so
that's an apology from here okay well
thank you council pass smalls next um
thank you matthew um i don't want to
repeat what uh councillor humphreys has
said but i i'm very happy to second this
what i would like to say is i think it's
been a well put together application
if only other developers actually took
as much time and trouble to consult
local people the fact you've got support
of the parish council and general
agreement from elsewhere i think is very
very commendable and it also saved us an
awful lot of time having uh protracted
debates and discussions in my opinion
one other thing i think john matheson
mentioned about the bungalow m3 that i
think that we probably need to put that
as a condition
you would agree with it i think it's a
very sensible uh suggestion so um
chairman without going into any other
details risk of repeating it i would
like to second this proposal if with
that extra condition as well thank you
yes cats uh trump mg what's going on
um that includes cycle link to priddman
avenue as well
okay council reborn
um thank you very much chair um i
i'm um i too am pleased to see that the
um level of consultation that belway
have done with the local ward members
district and county and the parish
council on residence
and um i'm pleased to see that um
the sustainability within the housing
such as the air source heat pumps so um
unlike last month um the
so i you know that it's pleasing to see
that and also that that this scheme has
been
amended and i think it's good to bring
it
you know forward in this way because um
you know it shows what has been
what has been changed and what the what
the community have asked for um
i would just you know i i do want to
surely get that
um northern boundary correct because i
think that is going to be a source of of
um
you know irritant to a resident so we
don't get it correct and and we do need
to ensure that that is a sufficient
you know and i think i i don't think
like where possible i think it's got to
be something and it's up for the
developer to decide how the houses are
positioned or the gardens and so off so
um and i would just want assurance at
that leap play area in the section 106
it says delivery that is
actually
providing it paying for it providing it
i would like confirmation that
that is the case
but
otherwise and and i'd also would want to
ask
whether we can just put where that
railway crossing is
acros uh that pedestrian crossing cross
a railway line is there some way we can
just put i don't know if it's more
signage or
prevent
i say kids but for anyone from kind of
you know rushing onto it or whatever
just to really ensure the safety of that
crossing while we've got the opportunity
at this site so if anything can be done
um with that regard i'd i think it would
be useful but otherwise i'd be happy to
support this as it is thank you
um just to
i don't really want to get into that too
much other than um the leap is
definitely paid for as far as the 106 is
concerned so it has to be provided by
the applicant or they they have to
provide all the money to make sure it
can be provided
so that's that's dealt with the
specification of that would be agreed by
us as well um
just looking at the uh the landscape
buffer again
we can reverse it around the other way
around which is to say it shall achieve
five meters in depth unless otherwise
agreed i still feel that there is some
there is some degree of flexibility
needed there for some of the plots
because
it's just impractical
thank you um council maths and then
councillor mansell
thank you yes um yeah
and having seen
the the very the
beginnings of this um
it's it's it speaks to the benefits of
site visits and it speaks to the
benefits of of good engagement with with
the with the applicant and so on and
that that's all very welcome
so
just
small points that we can perhaps try and
get um i want incidentally just to say
on the affordable layout originally all
the affordables were by the railway
even that's been improved um it might
not be ideal but that it was improved
um
so i think we should
make sure that the um pritiman avenue
cul-de-sac entrance is capable of
emergency vehicle use just to make sure
that's
i mean if we got it there anyway it
would be foolish to not make it vehicly
usable for that purpose
we've done lots lots of others like that
one
and um we've got the m43s one bungalow
in the market um
sector um so that's the conditional
right
and um the only other thing was i've
just really to say to to bellway
please consider offering
people the option of of pv panels on the
roofs
to help with the electricity for the air
source heat pumps um
that's a marketing point but it's a lot
cheaper to put them on when you're
building the houses than it is
retrofitting them afterwards thank you
and obviously supporting this thank you
councilman
uh thank you chair um i i i too think
it's great that uh bellway have
worked with the
community to provide to to provide
something that is acceptable to the
county council to the parish council
i'm a little bit disappointed in the
fact that there are
um so few two-bedroom market dwellings
um and unfortunately we don't have a
policy
to um
ask developers to put more smaller
dwellings
and
i think it's also a bit disappointing
that we have one out of the 85 that
doesn't meet the
national space standards you would have
thought one well couldn't we just have
had them all um that that would make it
better um i'm a bit intrigued by the um
the level crossing issue um and i happen
to have just looked up on the web
that back to ip144 and s which i believe
is the one we're um disputing here
that's next to this account has not been
granted uh a closure order like others
um across our county um and yet national
rail don't seem to have been a
consultant
um about this development i don't know
whether they were for the outline um but
living in a village which also has
railways and and crossings and i know
that that network rail insisted on
closing
one of the crossings adjacent to a large
housing development
so i'm a little bit intrigued that they
haven't had anything to say especially
given that the ward member has just said
that although the visibility is good
it is quite dangerous i mean that's on
the main line where i live we only have
the the slower trains anyway um and
so it is a bit of a concern that that um
the residents of 85 new dwellings might
all be rushing across the the um foot
foot the pedestrian level crossing to
get to the football pitches um
uh so
i i i don't know i don't think there are
any grounds to
uh to not support this uh application
but um
the more that people are talking about
this level crossing the more concerned i
am actually in the fact that network
rail don't even seem to have made a
comment
well then it's not listed in our list of
um things in our papers anyway so maybe
uh someone can correct me on that well
we'll leave uh john pmg to have a look
at that uh and cancer field do you want
to go next and we'll come back to that
point just briefly really on avoid
saying again what everybody else has
said but just to congratulate the
company
on its liaison with the
local world member and the parish
councils etc i think that that's good
and i i think there's some evidence that
they've been doing that elsewhere
and on the
air source heat pumps although i'm given
to understand the lack of gas in the
area probably does encourage that
decision but it is one we
i certainly welcome
and i'll leave it at that
okay can you answer that question about
network rail
my memory of our requirement is that
anything within 10 meters
um sorry john you have
i was just trying to see what we
consulted and i just want to double
check something but um
we should consult network value in terms
of anything within 10 meters
um i'm just checking now that we have
so
just bear with me while this computer
has decided not to do anything uh bear
with me i'll just double check
oh come on
can i come back to you in a second i'm
just waiting for this lower double yeah
i think everyone's spoken who wants to
speak i'm not going to add anything more
i think it's all been said councilman
you're happy everything's been said
as we're waiting for john um there was a
lot of anxiety about the railway
crossing at the earlier stage as well um
yes
just quite important
unfortunately i've just got the uh the
circle of death going around um
well ian i mean if we haven't consulted
the network rail
uh what does that mean and can we
approve it's subject to consultation and
conversations with networkrail about
improved safety at that crossing point
or how do we deal with it
is it
still waiting for it is
it is if i can just make sure i've
understood properly from john it is our
practice to consult network relevant
so our statutory duty is publicity for
applications for planning permission
within 10 meters of a relevant railway
land
we are required to publicize an
application for planning permission by
serving notice on the infrastructure
manager of relevant railway land so in
this case
um i have no record of that notification
being made right will it be on our
system i think the delegation needs to
ensure that we deal with that point
before a permission any permission is
issued so
we do as we issue uh can we issue can we
vote and it seems everyone's in favor
but then leave it with a condition that
the appropriate measures are put in
place with network rail and particularly
bearing in mind you've heard the
concerns about the railway crossing and
any additional measures that might be i
would
have to change our recommendation to you
uh to say that needs to be delegated to
officers um to only issue
uh
if it was an approval uh the the
decision subject to uh us looking at
that issue and negotiating consulting
i think are you happy on that basis
um as the proposer and second
okay so can you just run through the
wording just so that claire can put it
on this
the vote so that when we go to the vote
we're using the right wording please
so do you want to summarize where we are
so your recommendation is as your papers
except that it shall be delegated to
planning officers
to
notify network rail the
statutory undertaker for the railway
land
and subject to no issues raised
from that
um that it goes as recommendation with
the addition of two conditions one is
cycle link to prettyman avenue being
being agreed
and notwithstanding the details received
that the plans for the northern
landscape buffer to achieve five meters
in depth unless otherwise agreed by the
local planning authority including
details of access arrangements
and thereafter those details shall be
retained as agreed
uh therefore thereafter
oh sorry for free bungalow right
i didn't hear that one earlier
okay good and that's been
proposed by councillor humphreys and
sector by councillor passmore and if we
can now go to a vote please
john can i just confirm that you're
happy with the wording i've got here
hold on i'll read out to you once my
system lets me confirm it
okay
i'm
so i've got application be approved as
detailed from the office of
recommendation and the additional
conditions as i read out by the error
planning manager will that cover
everything for you
um you need to change it to delegate to
the head of planning
so
just at the beginning it just needs to
be delegate to header planning
oh actually you're right it doesn't say
jelly doesn't say quran does it so
delegate to i think it's the point is
it's subject to uh the consultation of
network well
so it can be what you've said okay
so that vote is now in progress members
humphreys thank you
okay shall i take your vote verbally
thank you
that is
eight votes for chair that's carried
okay
okay everyone well thank you very much
um what i propose to do is to take a
30-minute break for lunch the canteen
closes at 1 30. so if we did another one
now then we get no lunch so i think we
better break now quickly for half hour
so we can get down to the ground floor
and we'll start again at
1 40 please
okay welcome back everyone uh so we're
going to just uh move the agenda around
slightly because we've had some people
waiting here since first thing this
morning
so we're going to go straight to 7d and
then come back to 7c
so that's on page 275 of our papers
which is planning application number dc
2103589
i'll hand over to alex scott who's going
to take us through the application
and thank you chairman um yes members
this is item 7d application reference dc
oblique 21 of leak zero three five eight
nine land to the rear of the lease in
coits meadows donna massville
uh the application before you is an
application for approval of reserve
matters and conditions attached to
outline
planning uh permission reference dc
oblique 18 oblique
04191 for five dwellings
um and the outline application was
approved by members at committee on the
30th of january 2019.
um matters of layout scale and
appearance and landscaping are for your
consideration today and matters of
principle and access have already been
addressed by way of the outline planning
commission
so if we move to the presentation
uh this is the location of standard
masterful within the district the
avoidance of doubt
um the approximate location of the site
um hopefully you can see that there that
little orange dot there and for
reference we have the
a140 and a120 crossroads and stone and
barnes is in this location just for a
point of reference
and the approximate location within
the village
and this is the site location here
hatched in the purple line edged in
orange
now the site does actually
um sit outside the settlement boundary
of the village as designated in the
current development plan
and
the village is designated as a
as a secondary settlement in the
development plan that
with sustainability for um
for housing development and and the like
um and the most significant um
constraint would be the uh setting of uh
orchard farmers farmhouse here which is
a grade 2 listed building
here is an aerial view of the site now
the site comprises part of the existing
horse paddock
which is accessed
directly via the street now the proposed
means of access to the site would not
be by this existing access it would be
via quits meadow and part of the
application is for the demolition of the
existing
house here at the leis
and i've got a detailed layout um in the
slides proceeding
this is the site location plan um
for the outline which was approved and
this would not change by where the
reserve matters so land
in question edged in red and land also
within the applicant's
ownership in blue
and this is the proposed layout so we
would have a
an access road leading from kwik's
meadow
uh to the uh to the five twelve legs
proposed and what we have here is uh
one two three um 1.5 story that's with
the second floor within the roof space
dwellings
and those are five bedroom dwellings and
we have two
full height two-story dwellings which
are four bedroom
and uh garage blocks uh
proposed in association with the 1.5
story dwellings as well
these are the elevations of the 1.5
story dwellings of plots 1 2 and 3 and
the associated garage elevations as well
and four plots four and five which are
the full height two-story dwellings
um this is the construction management
layout
as provided by the applicant
which shows uh parking and
temporary
infrastructure here when the site is
under construction as well as an
attenuation basin which is
just outside of a cycle within land
controlled by the applicant
and
just for completeness this is the
layout that was indicated at uh outline
stage
under some photographs this is the
entrance to coits meadow
and this is the
existing dwelling at the lees which is
proposed to be
removed as part of the proposal
and then another
view this is the lees here
and existing access from quits meadow
onto the street
and reverse view
and this is existing
um access to the site and the the field
beyond and this is orchard farmhouse
which is the uh grade two listed
building referred to earlier
another view of that there
and this is looking back uh past orchard
farmhouse now on your left
towards the street
at the point of existing access to the
paddock which is here
and then looking beyond that to the
field beyond
and then a few shots from that
agricultural access
and this is um
the rear boundary of the site to the
agricultural field beyond
and this has been provided by the
neighboring occupants from their window
at orchard farmhouse which is a listed
building a view across the existing
paddock
so that concludes the officer
presentation i sat out in your papers
officer recommendation for approval
thank you
what you haven't touched on is uh the
the application process because there
was an application that came forward was
it in uh for reserve matters that was
refused
uh yes that's correct i was refused on
delegated authority for uh several
reasons
the
applicant has since amended that and
there is a list of amendments provided
for you in paragraph 6.3 which i can go
through if that's helpful or um if
you're happy just to read that
yourselves would be useful just to
compare what is different between what
was refused and what we've got today
just so that you can understand what the
differences are okay sure sure um
i don't believe i have the the plan to
hand um however paragraph 6.3 does uh
set that out in writing that
that that's all i'm able to help with at
present chair i'm afraid without going
away and
sourcing that um
so the refusal for the reserve matters
uh previously was on three different
reasons
the first reason was a technicality on
the basis that the original house wasn't
going to be
demolished but ultimately the outline
had that as being demolished so there's
a technical thing it didn't comply with
the outline in any event
the second reason
picks up on
heritage issues um considered that the
um
proposal would not be um
let me just read this again bear with me
essentially we consider there was harm
to the listed building asset i'm
assuming
that's here we go orchard farmhouse so
orchard farmhouse did you say watershed
paddock in your presentation it's also
orchard farmhouse is the the nearest
listed building
uh to the south of the development
and ultimately the design layout was for
that application was not considered
appropriate in that it would
erode the historic raw character and
setting of the listed farmhouse
[Music]
without comparing one layout to the
other bear we
let's have a look
just the reason i'm asking is looking at
the net papers it seems that what we
refused was five
there's five houses there and we've got
an application for five houses so what
i'm trying to work out is why that was
refused and why this is not being
refused just the differences because
they were they were both the five houses
on the same location
okay there would be a moment
so we also had a residential amenity
issue on that refusal as well
um
in terms of the close proximity the
access word okay
have you got the layout you can just put
back up on there for me
yeah just leave it on there so that's
the proposed layout for this application
which is interesting well it
probably i can't give you both at the
same time to compare and contrast
ultimately the refuse layout was
essentially retaining the existing house
at the beginning of the access drive
and then you had four houses
in a compact arrangement uh within that
locality there
this goes back to the outline that
obviously gone to for five and we now
have this proposal for five
um
i haven't looked at the elevations to
see what differences there are
these are bungalows in part i think
these were two story houses
but i'd have to quickly check
so look
this has got two bungalows isn't it well
one and a half story
well okay sorry rooms in the roof as in
one and a half story though aren't they
two of them
the
previous designs were all
two-story as in full two-story
oh no they weren't so one of them wasn't
okay uh where do we take this
and ask see what others think sorry
that's just my starting questions yeah
counselor mansell first
uh thank you chair um i've got a couple
of questions um
there's a comment on our papers page 277
saying that
the
heritage
team
didn't provide any comments
and yet
the previous uh the outline and this
previous application for that that's
been refused both seemed to be
um refused or had issues with with
heritage so um
i'd just like to know what
you know
if they were asked for comments and they
just provided no comments i just find
that a bit odd and my second question is
the large green
um area either side of the sort of
access road which on one plane looks
like it's constructors car park or
something uh whose responsibility will
that be um once the uh houses are
completed
is that is that part of the garden of
one of the houses or or is it a
management plan or what
that large open space
um yes
the first question regarding heritage
comments um they were consulted formally
and we received a response as is uh
summarized in the um console t section
of the um report i'll just get it in
front of me just unclear page 277
yeah i don't have the page number sorry
um
so they say no comments will be provided
by the heritage team the proposals are
not considered to be significantly
harmful to warrant heritage involvement
and that that is all that they say um
now myself and um
my landline manager uh gemma did uh
double check this with uh the heritage
league simon bailey and um
he didn't want to comment further so
i i think those are the formal uh
comments of our heritage team
um now in terms of the the green area
either side of the access um that would
be a private access road and
private
open green areas
[Music]
within private
control so it would be up to
future occupants to
to deal with the maintenance of that
so will it be the joint responsibility
of the five
dwellings or is it one dwellings private
garden
i don't think it will be anybody's
private garden uh perhaps that's a
question for the applicant's agent so i
believe we have here
council eben
um thank you very much chair um
the
one aspect to me is the sort of
there's the increase in the size of
houses in terms of the
bedrooms so we've gone from
in the outline what would have been 14
or so bedrooms to
um 23.
um
i just wondered what's the
in why was that increased from
outline to to now
and secondly the
[Music]
you know i i was too struggling with the
difference between that one and i've got
on my screen the origin the previous one
that was refused and the only difference
is the house in the top right hand
corner is now that way and was
um
north south
and the and the
house in the right hand corner was
level with the one next to it where it's
been turned 90 degrees
plus they've been reduced by half a
story but
it seems to me that but surely the
heritage views
would be
similar but anyway so what why is the
difference in the bedroom sizes from
outline to this um really is my
main question and was advice from the
planning officer that's led to the
slight change in
in directional configuration of the
houses thank you
right
in terms of bedroom number um i mean
matters of um
scale appearance layout um all
reserved at uh outline stage um
so that detail is in front of you now
for your consideration
and
um
sorry the second question cancer
whether whether it was due to advice
from planning that has led to the
change in orientation of those two homes
thank you right okay um well the the
applicant um didn't come in for pre-app
specifically um on this latest revision
um
but um
as i understand the latest layout uh
scale and appearance has been informed
by the um
previous refusal so
but um we haven't the applicant wasn't
advised specifically by your officers on
that yeah john you want to come in
just a quick question myself actually
we've got a copy of the outline in the
papers
thank you
thank you so ultimately if members look
at the outline there is no control over
the number of bedrooms
imposed by planning condition and
therefore
we don't have that as a reserve matter
to deal with now
in terms of the changes from the um
refused
refused reserve matters to this one
ultimately there is a judgment here um
but in in the end
the changes are outlined on page 283 as
my colleague has said
uh they may be slight in your opinion
but that is obviously a matter of debate
and whether they are sufficient in your
opinion to overcome the any heritage
matters you may consider that will be a
matter of debate are
in this case we don't have a heritage
opinion they have decided that it does
not warrant them being involved and
unfortunately that is the position we
are in as officers before you
okay councilman
top do you have a distance between the
two it seems very narrow
i dare say
okay um
yes i don't have a precise figure but um
yeah
reasonably close as you can uh
the road leads to a um a green section
that doesn't appear to be in either
on the east there doesn't appear to be
in either house his garden i
would suspect that's being retained by
the owner
um for uh field access i believe that's
there yeah that's the well that's the
official yeah it's just yeah and i don't
know the indicative plan was very
different to this yes
it was so it might yeah
no question sorry
thank you any other yes counselor
password council madison yeah but very
very quickly could just clarify this
issue that's come up about the number of
bedrooms
am i right from the advice we've been
given that there isn't anything you can
actually do about it i know the parish
council raised that gone up was it 14 15
bedrooms to 23 but that's the way it is
and um there isn't anything as regards
legislation or policies that we have
that would do anything about it if we
wanted to
so your judgment today is on the
appearance of the building scale of the
building but scale is implied to be
physical dimensions of the building how
many bedrooms you pack into it
is not
before us
thanks very much uh councilman matheson
yeah i struggled alongside um councilman
with the heritage uh given that given
the you know reason for refusal on the
previous reserve matters
that was a struggle
um
but apart from that i noticed there's
nothing about the sustainability of the
design of the building from from
officers
and also there wasn't anything about
um
the
way services
um didn't seem to have
commented either as to whether that it
was satisfactory from their perspective
which
um
given the relatively narrow access road
is probably
another thing that you know
did we ask them um
and um
yeah i think they are the points of
question okay
did the waste team comment
um no i don't believe we've had a
response uh from them from the waste
teams whether we consulted them i'm uh
i'm unsure of um
but um in in terms of um
getting uh bin laurie's inside and i
will say the bin presentation points are
uh
actually proposed to be on coits meadow
itself
so there wouldn't be a requirement for
the binaries to go into the new estate
so yeah
management officers for
any comment on the sustainability of
these designs
well that would have been an outline
stage and um
i don't believe we did at the time we we
had a
we had a considerable lecture yesterday
in the planning training about uh about
that
and um
i think that what we were advised was
that we could be looking at it for it at
either stage
either stage of any other members that
were there perhaps
support me on that
um so um
yeah i think we ought to have asked them
frankly but um anyway do you want to
come in john
i'm so curious of how you've been
advised that you can apply that at
either stage uh reserve matters are only
the reserve matters you know you can
only judge the appearance
of something if it's been secured to
appear in the first place um so i'm i'm
curious about that but i'll come back to
that training issue maybe another
outside of this arena
in terms of the
outline there is no condition i'm just
looking through it
for
sustainability energy
so how much water the taps use etcetera
has not been secured for this
application
um
that i can see what was the other part
the other part was the waste services um
waste services are normally part of the
highways authority they tend to take the
consultation in and it gets split up
between them um
but we there was no record of them being
consulted
independently
now humphreys
mr jeff thank you um just um some
clarification please alex page uh 283 uh
6.3
and 6.2 talks about the removal of plots
one two and three from two story
previous to 1.5 that's not strictly true
i believe and that's why i need
clarification because on the in
indicated outline plan
plots one two they're in the north
they're now two story not one point five
and spot 3 is
sort of 1.5 so it's not correct so
and that would affect
well it's just not correct
paragraph 6.3 um i refer to the previous
reserve matters application which was
not and not the outline
apologies if that's not okay so
sorry if i may mr
so uh 6.3 you're absolutely right to
refer to that the changing so it says
here the changing of plots one two three
from two story to one point five but
they haven't changed to 1.5 because
they're two story
in plots one and two
if we're using the same logic of plot
number in which is number one which is
top left
moving all the way around in a clockwise
direction
[Applause]
on which page
okay fine so there's been a change of
plot numbering all right thank you that
has cleared up that thank you very much
mr chairman
thank you
okay any other questions okay so we'll
move on uh right so we go first of all
to the parish council uh rob stephenson
welcome you have three minutes over to
you
thank you stella mashable parish council
is disappointed that the report before
the planning committee ignores or
glosses over many of the legitimate
concerns raised about this planning
application i'd like to address some of
them now
so number one
it is known that details of the reserve
matters application must be in line with
the outline approval and significant
changes requiring new application
at outline stage the development was for
two two-bedroom semi-detached houses two
three-bedroom bungalows and one
four-bedroom house it is now two four
bedroom houses and three five bedroom
houses that have double garages with the
same roof line as the houses
this development is now almost twice the
scale of the development agreed outline
stage
it is our view that these changes are
significant and the current application
must be refused in a new application
made
number two the outline application
specifically mentioned the need for
smaller houses in the area and the local
supporter comments reflected this the
people who can afford four and
five-bedroom houses will not be working
in this hinterland village we believe
the focus should be on building the
right houses for local needs and this
proposal is not that
number three the significantly increased
development will create a doubling of
traffic with significant detriment
to the enjoyment of existing and future
residents of coits meadow by increased
noise and disturbance from vehicles
pedestrians and from vehicle headlights
at night time
number four the impact
on the significance and setting of the
grade two heritage asset we find it
concerning that the heritage team in a
report dated the 22nd of december 2020
found the scale and mass of housing
unacceptable
and objected to placing three-bedroom
bungalows where there are now
five-bedroom houses with double-height
garages and for this to be considered in
significant impact
the unnamed unreferenced undated
non-headed paper twenty word report
saying insignificant from the heritage
team does suggest the matter may not
have been thoroughly reviewed
question point five yeah the large
attenuation pond out is clearly outside
the red line we do not think the
committee
can be legitimately asked to approve a
drainage scheme with features which fall
outside the matter under consideration
the site under consideration
number 0.6 our concerns about the
positioning of the bin store alongside
the existing properties in coits meadow
meadows
and the excessive distances new
residents will be expected to drag them
has been ignored
number seven the lack of safe provision
for pedestrians is unacceptable and the
plans are silent on who will be
maintaining the verges
in conclusion the parish council does
not agree that the major increase in
scale of these buildings after outline
approval is acceptable and the impact on
the increase in scale and residential
immunity inherit and heritage assets
significantly outweigh the doubtful
public benefits of the proposal so we
therefore urge the planning committee to
respect and support the needs of the
village community and refuse the
application
thank you very much okay do we have any
questions for the parish council at all
yeah council maths yeah it
is um
is the lack of footways um
typical of new development
in in stoneham or um or is this this
would be an exception i mean as a
i think we could see there's a foot way
in in koi's meadow
apart from that
so coits meadow has a foot weight um all
the way around it
and you know it's a it's a family um
family houses the new development has
nothing and throughout the rest of
stoner masspel all the other cul-de-sacs
have footwears and pavements
okay thank you very much as there are no
other questions we'll now move on to an
objective beverly brady and welcome and
you have three minutes as well
thank you and good afternoon i'm
representing one two three and five
quaits meadow longshore orchard farm and
the landowner who farms immediately
behind the proposed site and owns the
adjoining track
the revised plans represent an
unacceptable 60 increase in property
size
not in line with outline approval how
can this be a reserve matter
we fail to see how five dwellings of
such size and occupancy can add value to
the mix of local housing where the need
is for housing which is affordable
the properties are out of character with
coits meadow instead of a bungalow we'd
be overshadowed by an oppressive
five-bedroom two-floor dwelling the
drainage basin still remains outside the
red line area integral and needs
separate approval
a serious concern is the relocation of
the contractors parking material storage
offloading bay site offices and
portaloos slap bang between three and
five points meadow
unsightly for residents and visitors for
months on end
how would you like to look out of your
lounge or bedroom window and have that
greet you
moving the builders compound to the
front of the development substantially
increases the noise disturbance and harm
to neighbours a major concern
particularly as adverse impact to the
character and appearance of the area was
a primary reason why the original
application was thrown out by planning
inspectorate
working from home mainly on conference
calls becomes nigh on unbearable for me
the bin store another unsightly addition
to the middle of our cul-de-sac
unnecessary if the access road was
genuinely adequate
increased traffic via a new unlit access
with no pavement seems ludicrous
how the idea of an access road cut
through the middle of our small
cul-de-sac isn't considered significant
is frankly beyond me
we're very surprised by the no comment
response from heritage their report on
the most recently refused application
was concerned by a medium level of
damage to the setting of the listed
building and comments from the planning
inspectorate previously also referred to
diminishing its setting
our secluded setting the boundary in
part being the wall of the leaves would
be gone
leaving our home of 15 years and much
loved garden exposed
devastating and a risk to our security
and privacy
the recent felling of two perfectly
healthy mature trees and the manner in
which it was done has already shown a
complete disregard for neighbours
it was highlighted last week the amount
of land already available and should be
a prime consideration against this
speculative green field application
overall we failed to see how the
planning office's report provides a
balanced representation of the facts
thank you
thank you very much that was bottom
three minutes thank you any questions at
all
no okay so now move on to craig beach
welcome and over to you and you have
three minutes as well please
this proposal is for five low energy
dwellings on the site which has outlined
planning approval for five dwellings
the council have previously confirmed
the site is suitable for development and
is a highly sustainable location set
center of the village within a short
walk of the village school
the houses have been carefully designed
utilizing a rural suffolk aesthetic
based on single-story brick barns for
three of the plots with room in the roof
and two-story timber-framed looking barn
buildings with black timber cladding and
brick and flint ground floors all have
red pantile roofs
the houses are positioned to reflect
typical barn style groupings set around
a fold yard thus the scheme sits
comfortably and is expecting expected
form and grouping within the village
the single story brick homes have a roof
space that is fully hipped to further
reduce massing but this contains the
bedrooms with roof lights to maximize
the use of space
high quality natural materials have been
used throughout materials that are
identifiable as being a rural suffolk
extensive landscaping is included in the
scheme including mixed native hedging to
all boundaries numerous native trees
being planted across the site and large
landscape gardens to each dwelling
as stated by your planning officer this
is a sustainable location with good
pedestrian connectivity and no adverse
impact on the natural environment or
biodiversity
the resultant development is considered
to be of a suitable density and design
character for the site
and area and provides interest and adds
a unique character
all statutory consultees offer no
objection highways environmental
protection flooding and drainage and
heritage officers in county archaeology
fully support the scheme
mid suffolk have noted in today's
committee report that the scheme
provides a high standard of immunity and
design has addressed the matters raised
by stun and parish council and will
create a new landscaped edge to the
village and provide suitable green
landscape screening and boundary
treatments
they say overall the development is
considered to provide an appropriate
addition to the village
we hope you will follow your planning
officer's recommendation for approval
thank you
thanks very much do we have any
questions at all yeah counselor manson
uh thank you
i'm particularly interested in your
comment saying that they were five low
energy dwellings um i can't don't seem
to recall anything in our papers about
the um
calm footprint or otherwise of these
dwellings so perhaps you could explain
to me what low energy features these
dwellings are proposed to have
um
these dwellings basically are going to
be highly insulated to passive house
standards and i think the reason the
applicant came to us was because they
were looking for low energy sustainable
dwellings um they'll feature air source
heat pumps electric car charging
um
and
low water use technologies so they're
not aimed to be passive house but
they're aiming to be above building
regulation standard
i think i think we had comments in
our design and access statement that
went with the application i think
thank you any other questions too
okay thank you for that i'll now move on
to the ward member
uh this is from councillor susie morley
who couldn't be here today
i really do not understand why this
application for reserved matters is
before you the committee
a previous application for reserve
matters on this site dc 2003 291
was refused because the application was
not in accordance with outline planning
permission
impact on significance of heritage asset
and impact on residential immunity
the current application continues to
fail on these grounds
reserved matters are not in accordance
with the outline planning permission
the proposed scale of this development
is over 60 percent bigger than that
indicated at outline planning stage
the single story houses indicated have
all been replaced by large two-story
properties
there has therefore been a significant
increase in scale and change in building
types
this materially alters the basis of the
decision to grant outline planning
permission
and is clearly not in accordance with
the outline planning permission
it should not be possible to consider
such a significantly larger scale
proposal under reserved matters
application
further planning permission should be
required for such a proposal and this
current application should be refused
the proposal includes and relies upon
unapproved development outside the
agreed red line area
the current plan indicate the
construction of an unapproved large
intervention pool
with associated drainage systems
and a potentially permanent contractus
compound
on agricultural land outside the red
line area see document 207 469 0005
at engineering layout
or 4703g
proposed site plan ground and others
these will have a significant impact and
lasting damage to the natural
environment and surface water
characteristics of the land
as well as on the setting and
significance of a nearby listed building
the proposed intervention pond is fed by
drains from the proposed development
and as such is an engineering operation
that forms an integral part of the
proposed development
it cannot consider
sorry it cannot be considered to be
agricultural work
it should therefore require planning
permission
the heritage offer gave detailed reasons
for refusal of the previous application
which were accepted and summarized by
the chief planning officer in the
refusal decision
the current application does not
mitigate the harm to the setting and
significance of the grade ii listed
orchard farm
and the public benefits of the proposed
development do not outweigh the level of
harm to the setting and significance of
this heritage asset
these remain architecturally massive
as two-story five-bedroom properties
with a six and a half meter ridge height
far removed from the small three-bed
bungalows shown in the approved
indicative plan
the new proposal places these massive
properties just as close to orchard farm
as the refused application
and worsens the situation by moving two
double height double garages to sit 10
meters nearer to the listed building
than they were in the refused plan
this latest application appears to
largely disregard the objections and
recommendations of the heritage officer
and the planning officer statement in
the previously refused application
and should be refused again on the
grounds of inappropriate scale and
layout
the heritage department comments which
previously objected to the development
now appear to have no objections to
amend the application
yet the latest proposal has clearly
increased detrimental impact on a grade
two listed building orchard farm
the village are not against development
as can be seen from their willingness to
engage and support a larger application
on the other side of the road
the village are all in favor of
appropriate development to support our
residents
however this application is in no one's
interest
please reject this district councillor
susie morley
okay so that's
yeah is that a question all straight
into it
straight into i'm
no um i'd just like to clarify
um
something that was mentioned in
councillor morley's
whatever you want to call it
representation about a permanent site
compound could you clara could the
planning office clarify whether there i
mean there's there's clearly
constructive parking and a sort of
compound um on one of the plans um but i
sort of assumed that that was temporary
whilst the the thing was being built but
councilor morley mentioned something
about it being permanently there so
could that be clarified please
so
i know we've got plan showing the
so this let's start again
outline plan permission granted
outline came with a number of conditions
some of those conditions are being
proposed as part of the reserve matters
before you now
one of those conditions is construction
management and as part of that that
requires a detail of understanding where
compound
buildings and storage materials and so
on might go that is shown on one of the
drawings
that is did that go on the screen yeah
and ultimately
that's what we've got i'm not aware of
any of that being outside the red line
plan
the only thing outside the red line plan
is the attenuation base
that's actually a very interesting one
um now
this doesn't happen very often
but there's but having discussed it
there's no reason it can't this is
probably going to be very difficult to
get your hedge around so bear with me
essentially we have conditioned
that we need to know how
surface water is going to be dealt with
in respect of this proposal and we did
that at the outline stage
but unusually their proposal isn't to
deal with it on site their proposal is
to do with it essentially off-site and
we've actually got details of that being
immediately next door to the site
to comply with the condition
there's nothing wrong with that because
they've given us what we wanted which is
details of how they're going to deal
with it and we can secure that to happen
however
they may still need separate planning
permission
for those engineering works to be judged
on its own merits as a separate matter
so
they are at their own risk that they may
not be able to comply with that
condition if they're not able to go
ahead with that in any event
a separate matter that had to come as a
separate application that's how i do it
i'm just checking there with ian but
that's how i read this so in in this
context
that
discussion is down the road and that's a
separate matter perhaps councilman
i i i i can understand the attenuation
base of being outside the red line area
i've got experience of that locally
i just wanted to clarify that that
construction compound area will go once
the houses are completed because that
wasn't what was implied in councillor
molly's
thing that that what will turn into that
grass sword either side of the well
that's the landscaping we've got so it
has to go to that to comply with the
landscaping if this was approved so uh
for the avoidance of doubt we can make
sure that's clarified in any decision
made but ultimately that that's how we
see this yes
um was there anything else
i just want to mention very quickly if i
may challenge um
scale has been talked about quite a lot
in various representations i hate to say
this but scale and layout were not part
of the outline so
and problem would outline i i when i get
an outline application i do tend to kind
of move the indicative plan out of the
way and just say right this is a big red
line around the site what could this
potentially be
extreme worst case scenario best
scenario um because that is what it is
there's a big red line
your job now is you now have the scale
you now have the appearance and the
layout before you
do you like it yes or no and for
planning grounds
thank you uh council even you had a
question we're on questions yes
thank you chair um yes thank you for
clarifying that on scale um john because
i was going to ask a question about that
that what we are looking at today is is
the number of houses were
you know we've got a number of houses
we're five years old
so you've got to deal with
we've got five yeah i can't deal with
the bedrooms yeah no it's a deal what
they look like yeah so we are
height scale appearance layout and if
you feel there's planning harm or not
that's your debate yeah so my question
was going to be we are just checking we
are considering scale at the moment but
we have got the number of
houses
my other two questions are there
um
there appear to have been there's some
comments about some trees having been
removed
and on the um
landscape
plans it shows trees in place
can i just check that the
applicant would have to replant or plant
mature trees in their place
to comply with that proposed layout on
slide eight
and um
secondly
on the heritage point
um
i'm still bemused by this but given the
appeal
the inspector's appeal mentions heritage
a lot um what what what was it in the
decision within mid-suffolk that said we
don't need heritage comments on this one
thank you
so in terms of landscaping can i just
clarify with the case officer um the two
trees at the front are part of the
landscaping scheme
um so they could there's nothing to stop
us removing those trees i don't know i'm
sorry so there were two there was a
couple of trees at the front of the
property and i understand they have been
removed um they were not protected and
so on that basis there's nothing
stopping just like me with the tree i've
got in the back garden i want to take
down next weekend sorry to say um it's
affecting my foundations
i'm removing that tree but there's
nothing to stop doing that and there's
nothing to stop the owner of this land
taking those two trees away because
they've got no tree preservation of
order and they're not in a conservation
area
so
that aside
in the landscaping scheme we've got two
trees proposed to go there
in the same locations but they could be
replacements similar locations so yes
the answer is yes we've got two trees
being planted
but my question is those trees are
mature trees and they even on this plan
here on page
338 slide eight they show
what i would consider large trees with a
big
canopy circle around them so am i
assuming that those are going to be
uh no normally trees are it'll just be a
tree will it okay they will be grown
eventually
okay the other part um you were
referring to was the heritage um
we consult heritage
that is the response we have before us
they have a triage system now um because
in terms of resources they need to work
out what they have time for in resource
terms and what they don't
and that is the triage response and
that's what we have
yeah
so i can ask another supplementary
question reference heritage
how much weight should we put on the um
the inspectors comments re heritage
so the
uh
that was for nine houses wasn't it
am i
so
i cannot tell you that you should not
give it any weight because that would be
wrong you can give it weight because of
the issues that it raised but i would
say you need to rate those issues in the
context of that scale of development
accordingly so
it is a material consideration
the refusal
previously was is also a material
consideration but again the
circumstances of that has changed in
terms of this application is different
to that one you need to mitigate you're
given a weight accordingly
we don't have in our papers do we the
reasons for refusal of dc2003291
no
oh yeah 366. sorry
yeah okay thank you
any other questions
uh no okay so we're now into debate in
the first hand that was counselor
matheson
thank you yeah i do have quite a lot of
problem with this we are actually
being asked and this is on to page 275
right at the beginning there description
development we we are being asked to to
to discharge
the um
the surface water drainage details and i
i'm really struggling
with the idea that we discharged them
given what's also been said um about the
the risks to the applicant and all the
rest of it um
that you know we haven't actually got
in front of us
a scheme for drainage that i can see
um so that that's that's it that's a
that's unless you tell me differently
and we have but i can't i can't quite
see that at the moment
um
i
the heritage
gap in what we've been presented is is
you know is very difficult as well
um yeah i've i've read that that refusal
of reserve matters um twice i think
and um and i'd have to say that that
one cannot describe something that meets
building regs as meeting a passive house
standard um
officers can perhaps help me but i think
that broadly speaking on the old
sustainable homes standards
we're up to about
four as as
as the current building rigs and passive
houses have got pretty much be six so i
i that doesn't that doesn't actually
stack up either but i i think
crucially also
is is the lack of those footways the
outline
which
presumably dealt with means of access
like people walking to their front doors
and so on um included footways the
footways have disappeared and that that
is
that is wrong and we've heard that the
bylaws the rest of the villagers got
footways
and
i just
you know if if that was what the outline
decision was then
it needs to be part of this one as well
and and um
yeah i remind people i i've had the site
visit i've seen the site and all the
rest of it
um i was probably part of the refusal in
2017 of the nine actually but you know
it's it's not a good it's not a good
enough scheme at the moment
okay councillor passman um thank you
very much uh matthew i think this is
actually quite a difficult one because
given that we have the number is set at
five there is nothing we can do about
that as i understand it might be wrong
so therefore we have to consider what is
the appropriate development for a plot
of this size which is was it 0.91
hectares which in
english or mild imperial measures is
that over two acres so the actual
land allocated per dwelling on average
is um going to be somewhere uh you know
approaching
a half an acre which is quite big
so
for me it's quite difficult to side
bearing in mind all the comments that
the objectives and the parish counts
have made about and the ward member
is it the right sort of housing
development for that if you were to go
to smaller houses
how would that look and i'm i'm i'm
definitely struggling with this because
if you had much smaller houses put in
such big plots is that the best use of
land that's another debatable point um
and i do think it's regrettable um you
know for a land that that size you would
have more houses but obviously inspector
says we have got five and it's as simple
as that so we have to decide is that the
best development four or five homes
on that site or not and i think the
officers have done a pretty good job on
that actually because
they don't have the flexibility either
um so i'm going to hear what other
people say for once on this one because
i am really struggling with this i
absolutely get the issues
is it the best use of van it would be
nice if there was a mix of houses so
there were some starter homes more
affordable and perhaps one or two bigger
ones but we have to deal with what we've
got
so thank you and if that helps or not
probably not okay councillor humphreys
mr thank you um yeah it is difficult and
i see it from all angles gotta be honest
with you i'll go to some of the comments
that are raised by some of the
objections such as
these extra bedrooms cause extra traffic
that's not scientifically true um
because they could be full of children
so we've got to be careful on some of
these things that are stated and in fact
if we had more houses there smaller
houses there would be more traffic so
it's that you know cake and eat it sort
of thing what do you want um
mr potentially actually made a good
point you know do you like it
on paper and looking at it's where i'd
like to live i do like it definitely and
and i think as councillor passmore said
for the the fact we've got a five houses
there anyway and the fact that they've
got all this open space that'd be a
great place to live and i do get the
parish council's point that you know it
doesn't give locals the opportunity of
buying low-cost houses within the
village
but it does allow people who want to
live in the country the opportunity of
buying a nice house
so there are two sides to every argument
the attenuation bay one you're right it
is interesting but it will be subject to
further planning and also it's
conditioned that nothing will happen
unless that plan comes forward so i'm
not too worried about the attenuation
side of it when we talk about footpaths
it's a cordy start i live in a cool
desert there are no footpaths and that's
pretty true of most modern estates
they don't have footpaths
because the passage of traffic through a
cul-de-sac is slow and not very often
so therefore it's quite safe and that's
the reason for it and also you don't
have to maintain it
i understand the contract the contractor
site well unfortunately there's got to
be a contract to site where he stores
his equipment
does his admin does his personal
ablutions and goes to work that's got to
be somewhere on the site when you look
at this site from above
that's the only place it can really go
isn't it because how do they build
around it so it's the logical place to
be honest with you so i understand why
they've done that and i also understand
that it is temporary of course it is
because once they finish the work
they're not going to leave their stuff
there
the biggest thing for me is the heritage
point but as mr peyton g said heritage
you've got no comments now i understand
the triage and they'll do it in levels
of importance i understand all that
the the one thing with a heritage bit
though is that i don't understand in all
this report and if we go back to section
6.3
where it talks about
um when i find it just bear with me
uh yeah the moving of two-story elements
at plot three further away from the
southwest boundary of the site and
further away from the listed building
improving its settings above blah blah
blah
well you've gone from a bungalow to a
five-bedroom 1.5 storey house how does
that improve it
and that's my dilemma with this
i get it i would honestly there's a
place i'd like to live so i'm in favor
of this
but i have got an issue with the
heritage side i don't see where that
improvement has been made and i
understand the heritage triage that they
haven't commented but the fact that they
haven't commented because they've got a
new triage system where they don't think
it's important doesn't mean that it's
all good to go
it just means they haven't commented so
to me it's the heritage issue
thank you
yeah i'll come in after councillor
mansell who was next
okay
thank you chair um
i am
i i i i'm struggling with this too
because
in a way
we've got this outline planning
commission for five dwellings on this
plot and i think the access is terribly
contrived
and
i think
whatever goes in there is going to cause
issues with the access
regardless of whether you want big
houses on big plots or small houses on
big plots
um these are enormous houses
um
i like the fact that they're
being built to passive standards um and
i've got all sorts of lovely
environmental features
um
but they're being designed to be a sort
of barn-like
courtyard
um
well coit's meadow looks like a sort of
1970s housing estate
um it's not a sort of barn-like farm
yard where we want everything looking
like barns
i'm i'm not in favor of things looking
like things that they're not and they're
not bombs they're new houses and their
new houses built to to high
environmental standards so let's make
them look like houses that are built to
high environmental standards not barns
um
but i i um
i i don't like i don't like the
development in this place but we're
stuck with it it's got planning
commission for five dwellings on it um
i i too i'm struggling with the heritage
okay they've got a triage system they've
triaged it and said no we don't want to
make any comments
is that because of workload i don't know
the very fact that that we've had
appeals
and um other decisions on this
particular plot
which have been refused and dismissed on
heritage grounds
i'm a complete loss as to why heritage
deemed this to be unworthy of comment
they are huge great buildings and i i'm
sorry if the previous application was
refused on heritage grounds because it
was going to cause some sort of
harm to the setting of a listed building
we've tweaked it slightly lowered the
roof line it's still a big house and
it's still near a listed building so i
would really like to know uh like have a
bit more detailed response
from heritage
um because i think that's probably about
all we've got to go on um
and with regards to the the lack of
pavements
um there are lots of developments and i
think it's a sort of modern trend that
we now have sort of shared surfaces i
don't know what the surface treatment of
this access road is
but lots of large housing estates have
you know the sort of cobbled e bits that
are
you know meant to encourage the cars to
slow down a bit because they're shared
with all sorts of things so you know
it's five houses i'm not convinced that
lack of pavements is a really big deal
um it's the fact that they're big houses
and we haven't got our uh response from
heritage uh and that is what is worrying
me most here i mean i don't like the
fact that five houses going here but we
can't do anything about that
thank you um
so i mean this is i agree this is a very
this is a very difficult one for me
actually the design is absolutely fine
uh i like to mix things up between 70s
80s 2021 you know barn i'm up for the
mix of variety
the biggest problem for me with it is
the orchard farms enlisted building and
previous application that came
before the council was refused on the
grounds of the impact of the listed
building as one of the reasons and there
are a whole list of reasons here
and what i'm trying to separate in my
mind is how is this different
and i'm not sure i can find enough
reasons as to why this new application
is any different to the one that was
refused
uh relatively recently
and my take on it is that heritage
should have commented i think as i'm
afraid i think as a before a planning
application comes to committee where the
whole reason for refusal was based very
importantly around heritage we should
have it probably insisted on having a
report
but therefore my natural position is to
re is for me personally i will not be
supporting i will be looking to refuse
this because
the applicant has the opportunity to go
to appeal
but the residents don't have that
opportunity if we approve it and i'm not
100 comfortable with it so i feel that's
a safer option for me
but um i've got a couple more hands have
gone up cancer field is next
are you tempted to just leave it as i
agree
um
i
i always have difficulty to be honest
with the concept of
indicative plans you know it says we had
when people made a previous decision
they had an indicative plan
um indicative doesn't to me imply that
you something that you should totally
ignore
a mere fairy tale it clearly gives
councillors
an idea of the form of development that
will be carried out but
i hear what the officers say
i get to the
heritage part and i find
that the
original judgment was that the
judgment of the effect of houses much
similar in scale to the current proposal
was that they generated a medium level
of less than substantial harm
we now seem to have moved well we've
actually got two paragraphs that
although there's no heritage comment do
talk about heritage issues
one of them says that we've moved from
uh a medium level to a very low to
negligible level of harm
so relatively small changes have
produced like two steps of difference at
least in the assessment
which to me is
barely believable
particularly in the lack of a formal
comment from heritage
next
sentence actually says your heritage
officers have been consulted on account
application and advise that the current
proposals do are not considered to be
sufficiently harmful to the significance
of the heritage accident
if i read that as a bit of english it
implies that i need to increase the
the damage that's done
these are not sufficiently harmful for
whatever purpose we do so there seems to
be some confusion and lack of input
there
obviously the third
reason in the original for rejection the
noisy issues
i wouldn't thought was still largely in
place so
i certainly won't be supporting this
thank you
councillor mansell
and my apologies
sorry i was looking that way
thank you chair um
i'm um
it's interesting comparing
you know what what we've got on this
application for versus one earlier today
when we had an overwhelming amount of
information and personally i'm not sure
i've got enough information here to make
a decision
that's my issue and there's
there's the points about the um surface
the surface water drainage
um there's points about heritage um
there's points about
sort of scale
um this points back to construction i'm
just not you know sure that i've got
i don't feel confident let's put it that
way that i've got enough information to
make her um what should be an informed
decision i've got grave concerns about
the heritage triage system in this case
because surely it's a tick box thing is
it within a certain meterage of a meter
distance of a listed building tick is it
has it been mentioned has it been a
reason for a previous refusal has
heritage tick has it you know as an
inspector mentioned a tick well if
heritage if it's tick tick tick then
surely they should look at it whereas if
it was no listed building nearby no
mentioning an appeal no mention
previously then absolutely triages
that's how it works so i'm we don't know
what the triage um
arrangements are but it it does seem
bizarre in in this instance and i think
i'd be
concerned that
you know where
our previous refusal is mentioned
heritage an appeal has mentioned
heritage and yet we're not we have
nothing here
but like i say there are the other
aspects um
such as surface water drainage
that
you know i think we we should be
considering plus the fact that there's
there's the scale element and we don't
have a we haven't really gone into in
detail but i don't feel there is a
um you know in terms of the measurements
of the buildings and the volume of them
and whether what the scale difference is
um from what was expected to outline
albeit that we weren't looking at scale
outline but i just bring john in on that
point because he's i think the points
you've raised he might want to comment
on
okay
i think i'm
hearing this right and i'm
growing a another point here that i'm
starting to think about which ian might
need to help me out with
ultimately you are concerned that you
have
inadequate information on the heritage
considerations to make a determination
in this case
and of course there is a risk that if we
make such a determination you we could
be argued to have made that on a false
basis so
i would say that german i would suggest
that maybe we do defer this item in
order to
talk to our heritage
colleagues and ask them for a very
specific consultation response
on the issues of this proposal
and that to my mind would be
a matter of risk management and it would
be a matter to ensure that you have
sufficient information in planning terms
to make a decision
yeah please check
um because i think
i would say because i i don't feel
confident i've got the information i
couldn't make a decision one way or
other so i would have been abstaining
which is something i never liked to do
because i think we should have
everything here to either say yes or to
say no so um
on the use do we have and we do have a
surface water scheme uh fully detailed
out but i don't think all of that was in
the papers was it
okay so can i can i just have uh i think
if we go i think that's actually the
best route as well i agree because the
thing is otherwise we you know i
i agree i can't support it because
there's not enough information so the
default position is one so that someone
has a p and a chance of appeal but i
think actually it'd be better to avoid
going to that at all and it'd be much
better to have a full report from
heritage brought before us so
but can i just i think we need to be do
this urgently
and get this back quickly and not you
know delay this now for months and
months so i would ask that we you do
please ask the heritage team to prepare
report you know with some speed uh we
have a couple of options in respect of
who to go to on that basis if necessary
okay
so i'd need a proposal and a second for
develop cancer costs more
so i'll formally propose we deferred the
decision
with the caveat that we do come back as
quickly as possible and the second are
from council matheson
um yeah i i wanted to to ask officers um
that
presumably we can assume um that there
is heritage harm from the various other
um submissions that we've had in the
past so mr patrick should be for the
heritage team to report on yeah well
what i wanted to look for and this is
before we got to the deferral um
proposal really was um you know what the
public benefit is that would balance the
the harm that we think we
we think we recognize
um and the other the other question is
if if the applicant is claiming um high
levels of sustainability
even under passive house standard then
can we have a report on what's actually
proposed from the
appropriate officer on that one
so i'm suggesting that members defer it
to seek expert heritage assessment and
review of the case
to inform your decision we cannot
bias that by imposing what their expert
opinion might be they might think it's
great
they might think it's awful we don't
know the whole point of this is to ask
for them to come back with a full
assessment
in terms of the passive house standard
well i was very uh encouraged to hear
that because we have no
control whatsoever in the outline to
require any level of environmental
benefit
that has not been secured
okay so it's been proposed uh uh by
council of pasmore seconded by council
madison uh that we defer this
and the reasons are clear because we
need more information particularly from
heritage
um is there anything else we need more
information on apart from that
can we just have clarity i think when we
come back around where the compound is
and how that's going to work uh that
would be useful and on the trees what's
being planted and what's not being
planted
yeah landscaping more generally
okay so we'll need to go to electronic
vote i'll hand over to claire
thank you chair
members your vote has been amended to
read um the application number
be dc2103589b
to seek an expert heritage assessment
and review and that is now in progress
thank you council humphreys
councillor field sorry if you want to
vote uh just by shouting
thank you
uh so that is eight votes for deferment
i just say i do apologize to the
applicant and to the parish council and
to the
neighbors because it's you know to go
through a whole day and not have a
conclusive decision is deeply
frustrating
but it is more important that we get the
decision right and we have all the
information before us so and thank you
for i know you had to give up the whole
day because you came here at 9 30 this
morning so thank you very much and we
will try and put this uh on a speed
track through so it comes back to us
quickly
thank you okay so we've we're only going
to have time for one more application
today
uh
the question is what are we going to do
next uh we can do
and i would suggest we go back to 7c
because people a lot of people got to go
at 4 o'clock
so i suggest we go back to 7c
which is
also the street and stoner mascot
i don't think we'll get to the ones
after then because we're going to lose
about half the committee at 4
o'clock no we don't
okay so this is these uh
let's let's take their seats
okay so this is dc 21 no it's not it's
dc
1902.99 the street and stunner master
and i'll hand over to daniel
thank you chair um yeah so this has
previously been to committee in uh
january 2020 where it was uh approved
for the residential development before
us
and for improvements the sports
facilities um an issue has arisen um
with regards to the drafting of the
section 106 that would sit behind this
application and it's with regards to the
delivery of facilities for the stoner
master football club
the application i set out um
has always intended this to be a lease
of facilities this donna master football
club
as set out in the report currently has
no benefit of lease so it has no
security of tenure it has no ability to
raise much funding from sports england
or
regional and national fas
and the signing of the least would allow
them to start doing this making use of
it and creating
facilities
and
as pointed out in the original report
the facilities that currently exist on
site are a little bit
past their best
so it was effectively to revert the
decision back to members to
ascertain if if they were content for
the transfer of the facilities to be
done via release to the football club
um with a condition within that lease
that it be
renewed at their leisure so effectively
they would
continue to be able to make use of the
facilities now in terms of the site
history um they've been on that site at
the gift of the landowner for some
significant period of time and the
landowner is content that within the
build out of the site that they'll be
able to always make
their training sessions and matches even
if that relies on the
delivery of pictures elsewhere and land
in the landowner's ownership
um so effectively
the resolution for the section 106 was
to secure affordable housing education
contributions the phase build out for
the site the transfer of the sports
facilities and for the management and
maintenance of the open space and play
facility facilities within the site
effectively
the red bullet point set out there would
be the change to the committee
resolution
so instead of transfer of sports
facilities it's for the lease of the
facilities to the football club
and if i quickly flick through we'll not
spend too much time
but if i come to the phasing plan
here
we have this section of development
which would come forward first so we'd
see the sports facilities come forward
along with some enabling development and
then the remainder of the development
would come forward as a phase two
and that development is a mix of
uh two and three bed houses and
bungalows
thank you
the technical so really this has come
before us because we need to just change
the word of the of the recommendation
which is on page 264
and
the wording has to change from
least
sorry before we talked about permanent
we've talked about transfer transfer
implies it's permanent but actually the
word we should have used was lease which
is not permanent yes in my report i sort
of thought transfer would cover a
multitude of sins actually the legalese
it should say lease but that is the
reason it's coming back yep cancer e
bernie castle mayor
um thank you chair um in in the um
papers um paragraph 3.1 3.2 page 263 um
it mentions a 21-year lease and daniel
you've just mentioned 25 so just if we
can just confirm that
and i'm just a bit concerned about the
wording because it says they have a
pressing need for sports facilities
which this application will deliver well
they already have sports facilities
they've got several football pitches and
in fact this development removes one of
those football pitches so um i
appreciate it's but the gift of the
landowner but it just seems oddwording
and
they'll be getting less facilities and
less pitches
so just could you
qualify that and also um is it seen that
a 25-year lease is
more um
uh stable or more more certain than the
transfer thank you
so in terms of uh the lease duration um
that has been updated to be 25 years so
apologies i haven't updated the report
to reflect that
in terms of the facilities that the
football club currently has access to
they do have a number of pitches um the
proposed development would improve the
quality of those pictures so we'd start
moving towards 4g
they'd have flood training areas they
don't currently have
and we've obviously got conditions
secured on that so that we can avoid
light spill into the surrounding
residential areas as well so when we
haven't got um
flood lights that are on all the time or
on when they aren't being used and we
can mitigate that issue of
light pollution in terms of transfer or
lease um the lease is what the football
club believe they are getting and it's
what they have signed up to and in many
ways i think it's what they prefer i
think if they have if they go to
transfer
they're then responsible for the
maintenance and upkeep of all of the
facilities themselves and while that has
benefits it also has drawbacks for club
that has never
had a lease or to manage in any any
other form so their preference is for
the lease and that's what's
um being delivered uh 25 years is about
a standard term for uh for this sort of
lease um and with regards to it there's
normally a repeat clause
built into them so
if landowner and tenant are happy to
it's normally taken as read that these
can then roll on
or if they want to vary they can vary
between themselves and normally that's
then just built in a trigger point so
any time between year
22 and 24
the tenants occupy um the tenants um
exercise that's the correct word their
their right to extend the lease and then
just another 25 years
rolls on from the end um it's a
situation a lot of our sports clubs
have um not many of them own their sites
they tend to lease them either from the
council or
church bodies actually thank you very
much councilman
okay any uh any other questions for the
case officer yeah
yeah are we i'll be confident that 25
years is is long enough for the for
sport england and the fa and people to
to make the grants that are necessary i
mean i'm familiar with a couple of cases
in stone market where the length of the
leases is
causing problems
to deliver the grants that are needed so
i you know
in yeah in terms of um in terms of the
grant funding obviously there are
certain deadlines that will run
alongside
that and it'll be for the the football
club themselves to make the
the applications in good time i think um
stone market football club have found
themselves in a bit of a
unusual situation with regards to
promotion and then and then delay in um
actually being able to do something but
i think they are
in a good position now um to start going
forward with that again so yeah i think
the the sports england and um
the fa bodies are generally been sort of
receptive to that and have been pretty
okay and in terms of
in terms of the lease itself if you
you're in planning terms if you are at
least running over seven years
it's sort of tantamount to be able to
submit your certificate a as if you own
the land so in planning terms they will
be able to bring forward their own
um
their own development if it required
planning permission on the site as if
they owned it so there would be those
freedoms for them as well
subject to whatever goes into the lease
with the landowner
[Music]
the full value will be delivered
um
and that what they paid for won't be
lost after x number of years or in 25
years in this case um if they do expect
football club
the football club is happy with 25 years
they are happy with it so i think
they're happy that we there's nothing we
can discuss on it i i think as well the
the development's going to deliver new
facilities so sports england have
already signed off on the design of
those and are happy with them
so you'd be moving into new facilities
that presumably wouldn't need
as much maintenance or improvement i
think the main issue in that regard
would be if if the football club
progresses up the of the pyramids too
quickly and certain requirements are
made of their um their ground but that's
it's not a planning issue at this point
okay i'm going to move this on i think
we've covered that ground if that's all
right so so do we have any questions on
the presentation for the officer no okay
so we don't have anyone from the parish
council we don't have an objector we
don't have a supporter we don't have the
applicant or agent and we don't have the
ward member so we'll go straight into
debate to discuss and reach the
conclusion yeah council humphreys sure
thank you i'll keep it really sweet
really simple read the recommendation it
says to accept or not it's discrepancy
we do and we discussed that and it is a
lease
um it's a really good lease and
everybody's happy and therefore i'd like
to move approval
councilman
okay
so we've got a proposal and a second out
and if we just
on the basis of the 25 year lease so
claire could i ask you to take us to an
electronic vote please
thank you chair
members i would just make that
vote live so that is now in progress
council humphreys
thank you
thank you councillor field
might be slightly higher because we've
gone backer
thank you
okay folks now we rattled through that
quicker than i thought and we have got
the applicant for the last application
has just arrived in the building so what
i propose to do is go straight to the
last application as the last one
um
yeah especially as they've just arrived
in good i know you've got to leave at
four o'clock
hopefully we will be done yeah but i
totally understand we've got five past
four
train yeah thank you thank you very much
so we'll go straight to the last
application type 7f
it's uh it is 7ft
so
and at the end of the meeting we will
just have to have a vote on deferring
that last application if it's past four
o'clock just for the in terms of order
the one we've missed
can i just come in on that one um
is there a possibility that we can take
it to committee b
instead
because uh the closing date for that
will be tomorrow so we have the
opportunity to just pop it across
okay
if you'd like to come and take a seat at
the front here
because we're going straight into your
application now your timings perfect
arrival
okay so the next application before us
is dc2100324
which is item agenda 7f land south of
south west of fairview in balaam hand
over to daniel cameron the case officer
thank you chair um
so just in addition as a verbal update
um we have additional comments from
baylen parish meeting that i think have
been circulated prior to
this meeting in response to
the application
the application um before you is for
change of use of land from equine used
to agricultural use um and involves the
erection of an agricultural barn and
construction of solar panels to roof
slope following the demolition of a
stable building and outstanding
this is the site itself um
previous applications on the site of
seeing a stable be erected and change of
use of land extending down into the
valley
here for uh equine use
to support the stable
this can be seen there
in the red and blue land so with regards
to the change of use back to
agricultural
that would be confined to the red line
area
you'll see here we're strongly within
the special landscape area
and then as well there are footpaths
members um that run from the village of
balaam on the other side of the valley
across the valley
yeah
here
is the application site roughly there i
think if memory serves
and so we have an existing stable
building l-shaped with surrounding hard
standing that's to be demolished as part
of this application
and then we have
the action of a
barn structure with two shipping
containers
here to provide storage
a fairly uh utilitarian in terms of
their design
and if we have the
photos this is a photo taken from the
site access and you can see across the
valley we've got the the housing on the
other side of the ridge that's balaam
village itself
and then we have the other direction we
have the existing stables
and then this is from balaam village
looking across
the valley we have a footpath running
down
the side of this property
and it's the resolution isn't great
members but you can just see the
proposed stable the stable and
neighboring barn mentioned in the report
here and if i flick further forward we
have a view
here
members can make out some tree planting
on the valley slope here that serves an
adjacent agricultural barn
and the stable is
here for you members
with regards to the recommendation in
front of you members is to refuse
planning permission
due to the landscape impact of the
proposed barn
we're in a special landscape area our
landscape consultants have
reviewed the application
initially it was for a much larger
structure
that's since been revised downwards
but our landscape consultants still
consider there to be a degree of harm
associated with the building
in terms of the planning history we have
two appeals
one on this site one on the neighbouring
site
for residential
development
both of those
the inspector found
harm to the landscape area as well
um with regards to um
comments members comments made by the
parish meeting do no
potential for in their view for
additional um
reasons for refusal that members might
want to explore during their debate um
[Music]
one of those is whether the site is for
an agricultural use
in planning terms and agricultural uses
one which produces crop or raises
animals for consumption
it's the view of officers that the
application does represent an
agricultural use
[Music]
comment is also made um
by um
some of the neighboring
properties and by apparently about the
viability of the business
being proposed
we aren't being asked to make a judgment
on whether the business is viable or not
that would be borne out if planning were
granted if the business managed to turn
a profit and survive um that would be a
risk for the applicant to take
themselves
um the other the other issue to note um
and that's brought up in the calling
request
um
is
harm to the highway and um additional
vehicle movements from
from the barn causing a degree of harm
we have no adverse harm identified by
our highways consultants at suffolk
county council
and no issues were noted on the previous
applications
on the site for residential development
either dc 190496
or dc
19028 so
that first one was um residential
development which was refused in
dismissive appeal and the second one was
for the erection of the stable that
noted that
highways traffic movements would be an
issue of such adverse harm that it
should be
its own reason for refusal on those
applications
the parish meeting do know the adjacent
development of the um
apple orchard and barn dc 180402
and note the conditions were applied to
that to control highways movements to a
degree
but that's again something that members
might want to bear out in debate
um
if they are minded to approve the
application against the officer's
recommendation but
pass back to members for questions and
on to debate
thank you very much okay any questions
for the case officer councillor
humphreys thank you mr chairs one
question i couldn't find it in there so
rather than look even further i'll just
ask what's the difference in size of the
proposed building
in height and length to the existing
stables
in length and height it is greater um
than the existing stables i think i
detail it in the design section i'm
hoping so i'll have it set
two out
no it's probably in section seven
um so the overall footprint of the barn
has been reduced from 364 square meters
to 126 square meters
um the proposed barn is taller than the
existing it'd be five meters is rich
compared to 2.75
yeah five meters at his ridge the
existing stable is two point seven five
meters at his ridge
any other questions yeah councilor
madison then councillor thieving
castleman yeah did
as you were
wanting to refuse it did you ask um
councillor norris if you'd like to
withdraw the calling and save us all the
trouble
um
so i think once it's written it's
written yeah i've i've also um picked
this application up from a previous
officer and i think indications
um there were that they were more um
they were minded to approve the
application now a difference of opinion
between officers is is to be expected
but
yeah it is it is what it is councillor
field
thank you might be an issue by hearing i
think council uh umph is asked about the
difference between the proposal and the
existing building and i think you quoted
2.7 versus 5 meters high the area you
mentioned
it's very much
the current proposal is much bigger than
the stables i think so i'm not sure you
answered that originally 364 square
meters
for the barn then reduced to 126 as
opposed to 63 meters squared for the
stables
and council mayor
thank you
you mentioned um shipping containers
are there any proposals to screen those
in any way
um i think it would be within members
gift if they were
minded to approve the application
to include screening we could look at
a colour scheme for the containers but i
think screening might be more
appropriate
the circular road has some mature
vegetation on it anyway and you'll be
behind the barn so in some respects the
shipping containers would already
already be screened across views within
the special landscape area it's on the
other side
you'd probably want to consider that
thank you any other questions cancer
field
uh asked for a moment about the
agricultural nature of this proposal i
mean the original
larger barn as i understood it had sort
of greenhouse areas and therefore was
for the growing of crops
you know if you like a natural way this
building appears to have no such
facilities so implies that crops are
entirely grown within it does that still
remain within the agricultural
definition
it would i mean effectively it would be
similar to um you know the difference
between a free-range chicken shed and a
um
a more intensive process um
okay so in one the chickens are kept
within the confines of the building
24 hours a day it's still an
agricultural use for the
production of food
if we were talking about taking a food
crop and then applying an industrial
process to it
change it to something else i think
that's when we'd then be looking at an
industrial process rather than
agricultural use
okay no other questions so we'll move on
uh so we have from the parish council
kevin thomas from bail polish meeting
welcome and you have three minutes and
over to you
since the proposal under consideration
is in fact an intensive food production
facility balaam parish asserts that the
council's policies controlling the
location and development of new business
in the countryside and material and
should be considered as council and
norris has already indicated
we'd like to take this opportunity to
bring relevant sections of these
policies to the committee's attention so
under section 25 industry and commerce
policy e9
location of new business
so the proposals for
oh
excuse me i'm just gonna have to
scroll my screen
i apologize
so section two five industry and
commerce policy e9 location of new
business the proposals for a new
business which this is will be permitted
providing that there is no demonstrable
harm to road safety residential immunity
or the environment generally
under road safety the lane from the site
triple 1 3 is designated unsafe for
accompanied children it's used by
walkers and with and without children
and dogs cyclists and horse riders the
lane will necessarily be made more
dangerous by an any increase in traffic
flows the application doesn't indicate
associated traffic movements but the
micro greens business is driven by low
volume customers requiring frequent
delivery existing businesses found
through google search supply in effect
the united kingdom
and or are
situated in urban dwellings
this policy states the proposals may be
acceptable on small sites closely
related to existing built up area for
town or village provided that
the buildings proposed were appropriate
in design scale and size
play services landing landscapes has
indicated they're not provided that
there is no significant adverse impact
on residential
amenity so distress is already caused to
the 20 or so sight-facing homes by
existing commercial operations up on
that ridge through noise and
paraphernalia littering the site as well
as its dominating position overlooking
the village
provided that access can be provided to
the highway to highway authority
standards and there is no evidence
that the restricted display to the west
on leaving the site has been evaluated
for commercial traffic
provided that the site is well related
to the local highway network well this
site is very poorly related to the
network being a narrow single lane track
with restricted visibility
policy e10 new industrial and commercial
development in the countryside states
that applications will not be permitted
unless an overriding need to be located
away from towns and villages can be
demonstrated
there is no overriding need demonstrated
and indeed microgreen production is in
many ways better suited to an urban
environment
finally policy e12 the general
principles of location design and layout
of commercial development state
that proper considerations should be
given to the scale of the building which
has already been discussed the sighting
and layout should where practical take
advantage of the possible need for
future expansion this barn is already as
big as it can be
and therefore there is none
and this is particularly important it
states that no open storage of goods
containers waste materials or finished
products will be allowed if such
activity is considered visually
unacceptable and this clause
is effectively conditioned into the
neighboring barn that's preventing the
use of containers the last sentence
please the last sentence is
however
and irrespective of any of the arguments
above
a grant of application would result in
an irreversible degradation of the
immunity of a special landscape area
which the council
is required to protect under its own
policies thank you very
lpas i'm much excuse me excuse me excuse
me
you've had you had i gave you an extra
20 seconds and you only get three
minutes that's fine thank you very much
just by keep going thinking we're going
to listen really doesn't isn't the way
we do things in mid-suffolk we respect
the time keeping
thank you
any questions for the parish council
no thank you
okay members uh i will now read out a
comment from councillor norris
uh i'm unable to present to the
committee uh meeting next wednesday as
my wife and i'll be attending a funeral
so please accept this email as my
comments as the ward member and respect
to the above application i'm fully
supported the planning office's
recommendation for refusal of this
application
further to the reasons given for the
call in on page 401 of the papers the
application refers to the erection of an
agricultural barn
however the dictionary definition of
agriculture is cultivation of the soil
and rearing of animals
the proposed barn would not fulfill
either of these purposes
instead the intended use
is to house the intensive commercial
production of micro greens flowers
vegetables and fruits
revised from the original stated purpose
of growing mushrooms and micro greens
nonetheless there would still be an
inevitable increase in traffic movements
along a narrow country lane with no
footpaths which is much used by
pedestrians and dog walkers
the overriding and perhaps most relevant
impact of the proposed barn as it would
be located on a bridge within a special
landscape area
where it would be prominent with
considerable impact on the surrounding
countryside and the environment
this application is not supported by
place services landscaping on page 390
of the papers
where they have stated that despite a
reduction in the size of the proposed
building
from what was originally proposed
they consider the scale and prominent
position the barn would still have a
significant impact on the landscape
for the reasons and those detailed in
the call-in on page 401
i'm unable to support this application
counselor mike
norris okay members so that's all the
information before us it's up to us to
discuss debate and come to a conclusion
counselor eben
um thank you chair um i think this is
a fairly
cut and dried case really
it's one of those cases when we should
be relying on our technical experts as
such as those in the um
place services for landscape
and
we you know the reason special landscape
areas are called such is because they
have they are special landscape areas
and they have protections accordingly
and i think particularly not you know
both the
increased size of the building plus the
shipping containers um
i think we should um
personally i will be supporting the
officer's um recommendation for refusal
thank you
um thank you matthew yeah i think um the
thing that does it for me it's the
impact on the landscape i do want to
make the point that growing of micro
greens vegetables fruit etc is a
legitimate agricultural activity and
there are all sorts of potential
environmental benefits regarding scarce
natural resources water resource and
everything else so we've got to be
careful not to in my opinion um discount
things like that it's highly innovative
and we are in some cases uk plc world
leaders in this technology but
the size of this and the location for me
i think does make it
the wrong
um the wrong place and therefore i would
be supporting the officer's
recommendation i will move refusal on
the grounds of the impact on the
landscape thank you that's all council
humphreys
mr chair thank you uh similar vane
really if you go to page 397 um it talks
about it being of a similar size to a
bar that's already there on that ridge
in that area of special landscape
however that was then that wasn't us and
this is now and we've got a plan in
front of us that actually would be a
blot on that landscape so
due to its size due to its location
i again would was also recommend that we
go along with the recommendation uh have
you made a proposal
then i'd like to second that proposal
thank you
councilman yeah i just i just was always
also queuing up to um
to second that really i i've looked at
this particular site not in the context
of the application but i've been i've
looked at it from both sides and it's
absolutely it's a lovely bit of
landscape you can see why it's an sla
and so i support refusal
okay so i think on that basis we'll go
to a vote please claire
thank you chair
remembers that vote is now in progress
councilor humphreys thank you
councillor field
thank you
thank you members chair that is eight
votes for refusal
thank you
okay thank you very much now um the next
application um is is somewhat complex so
i'm going to
prepare that we defer that um to the
next committee meeting which will
probably go to committee meeting b in a
week's time um so i would need a
proposal to defer that and to close the
meeting councilor manson
i'll just for our proposed deferral of
item
7e i believe it is thank you very much
and can i have a second up please
councillor field thank you
we'll need to go to an electronic vote
thank you chair
that vote's now in progress council
humphreys thank you councillor field
thank you
thank you chair that's eight votes for
deferral that's unanimous
okay is agenda item eight uh do we have
any site inspection requests reported to
the committee
i'm receiving okay well thanks very much
uh see everyone in four weeks
uh it's 3 32. have a good rest of the
afternoon
you